good morning everybody and welcome to
the meeting of development control B
committee my name's Kathy gri and I'm
the chairman today for some of the
occasion and it will be revealed shortly
while in a minute may I first of all
remind you of some domestic arrangements
please ensure that microphones are muted
when you're not speaking that you do not
interrupt the other speaker members are
reminded not to use the messaging emojis
chat function during the meeting unless
it is to report a pecuniary
non-pecuniary interest or to notify the
chair that you wish to make a proposal
members are reminded they should not
have alternative communication lines
open I.E other team chats and that if
you are contacted by a third party
during an application you should bring
this to the legal advisor's attention
that if you attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
Additionally you will be invited to
speak and ask questions by myself or the
chair at the time councelor Humphries
please await your turn we will not be
using the hands up function except for
Declarations of Interest site visit
requests Declarations of lobbying and
questions for
clarity we will be using electronic
voting for this meeting if you're
experiencing poor connection issues in
the first instance please turn off your
camera if this does not work please turn
off all incoming video these options are
under the three dots on the main
information bar I would like to remind
everyone present that this meeting will
be broadcast live to the internet and
will be capable of repeated viewing the
whole of the meeting will be recorded
except whether a confidential and accept
or exempt items to make a representation
to the meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
recorded by entering this meeting as a
speaker you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council and to the
possible use of those sound recordings
for webcasting and or training
purposes the council members of the
public and press May record film
photograph or broadcast this meeting
when the public and press are not
lawfully
excluded so if we go on to introductions
please in Pre our legal advisor are you
there um yes good morning Madam chair
ladies and
gentlemen thank you very much Robert
Carmichael governance
officer good morning
chair thank you John pman G and Gemma
Walker are area planning managers are
you both
there good morning it's I'm here John P
G I will apologize for a lack of video
it unfortunately has over heated and
decided to break down for this morning I
will see if I can reset it later but uh
I am here thank you for that and Jemma
are you there yeah good morning chair
yes I'm here as well thank you and Alex
Scott case officer are you
here uh yes I'm here chairman good
morning good morning to you thank you
very much indeed we will have Ward
members um but they are for later items
although I will be the ward member for
the first three items which I will just
move on to very shortly so can we move
to the agenda please apologies for
absence and
substitutions so thank you chair we have
apologies this morning from councelor
James carsten and councelor Richard
mayor is substituting for him thank you
very
much to receive do you wish to make a
roll call there isn't a note of it here
but we sometimes do but I think we're
all here what do you what would you like
to do as the governance officer please
uh it's your discretion chair um we've
checked that members are here on the
modern. goov app so I believe that that
is fine right lovely thank you very much
indeed to receive Declarations of Peary
and non-pecuniary interest by members
and are there any to declare and you can
use the hands up function thank you
councelor War
boys uh yes I think this is a
non-pecuniary interest I'm the
membership secretary for the wavy branch
of camera the campaign for real ale um
debam is in that area so I probably have
a non peculiar interest in the in items
7D and
7e possibly 7B but that's not in my
area in are you happy with that thank
you yes indeed Madam chair that that's
well I think it's if it is a an interest
at all it's a non-pecuniary interest
it's exactly cleared out of a
commendable um wish to be fough but yes
indeed no problem excellent thank you
very much thank you Declarations of
lobbying are there any to declare mam
chair I've also got a non-pecuniary
interest oh I do beg you pardon I'm
sorry I hadn't seen that I beg you
pardon no problem thank you it's non
commun interest gun cottonway uh I'm a
town counselor also on the town planning
committee but it's outside of my ward
and therefore I don't feel it prevents
me on
voting thank you for that information
there any more I'll have a little look
around
no right so Declarations of
lobbying um as Ward member I'm entitled
to receive um lobbying from um
applicants and members which I have but
that's as Ward member and um yes
councilor Mo
um I received uh emails reference the
anchor storage dc2
04987 councilor W thank you for that
councelor war
boys did you did you get lobbying
councelor War boys anyone else I the
hands up are getting a bit confusing for
me
here yes I did I I had I've had some
emails about the
um this is the landre of the six bells
and also the
um the the one uh where we we um it's
the loss of
um employable space forgot the number
the first one what was the first one on
December yeah yeah DC
24723 yes indeed um indeed I did receive
something on that as well um anyone else
Stringer thank thank you chair yes I've
received some emails lobbying on behalf
of item C in Kenton Lely thank you very
much Madam chair counc G here uh me also
on on the anchor storage Kenton
application thank you very much indeed
and anyone else yeah Madam chair
councelor melan here um I've had uh
emails regarding um Item B the felim
application thank you very much
indeed and anyone
else that we've missed yes it's very
confusing this the hands up thing is
disappearing it just says for but you
don't know who they are so I really do
apologize right we're done on that any
Declarations of personal site visits
please no there appear to be
none confirmation of the minutes of the
meeting held on the third of March are
there any points of accuracy to the
minutes
please any hands up on that one
no right could I have a proposal
please
Mike Norris I'm happy to propose thank
you very much councelor Norris
oh
sorry um council hre is happy to Second
thank you very much
indeed can you cont conduct an
electronic vote on that
please please go to the modern. goov app
for today's meeting go on today's agenda
and go to the plus sign in the top right
hand
corner when you click on that the
subsection will come up of attendance
and voting and the vote will be shown in
a light blue color which is now in
progress members do have any difficulty
please um please let me
know
for
thank you chair all votes have been
received and the result of the Voting is
seven votes for and one abstention thank
you very much as an appropriate time I
will sign those minutes do we have
notification of petitions in accordance
with the council's petition scheme
please yes chair we have received one
relevant petition which is associated
with uh the item
seven I just get the reference number
sorry item 7B on our agenda which is
application
dc20
04572 land rear of six bells Church Road
felim and I will just read out the
petition with its valid number of
signatures so 183 valid signatur
have signed the supporting statement as
follows so we the undersigned residents
of fum urgently requests that SEC
highways reconsider its decision to
approve the developers claim that Church
Road would be a uniform width along the
whole of the road and thereby proposer
proposed to put edge of carriageway
markings at its widest section in front
of the six spells Pub and its access to
the application site to enable the
developer to just ify that visibility
spays are safe in order to get planning
application approval the proposed edge
of carriageway markings will narrow the
road to 5.5 m and with vehicles parked
along this section of Church Road using
the village community shop visiting the
church and its Church yard patrons of
the pub and nearby residents with no
off-road parking it will create a single
file traffic system with nowhere to pull
into as at present and allow oncom
oncoming traffic to pass safely
the risk of a collision personal injury
or fatality this will create is
significant and therefore decision to
approve this reduction of Road width
must be overturned and objected to on
grounds of safety thank you
chair thank you for that now the
schedule of planning applications there
is a change to the order as listed in
the agenda we will now um be dealing
with them in the following order DC
which is the angel in deham followed by
dc20
0596 which also relates to the angel
deam we would then deal with
dc20
04987 the Kenton anchor storage
application and followed by dc20
0472 3 which is the site C and 3D south
of gunot way Stow market and finally
dc24 572
falam right with further Ado as the
first three items are in my ward I will
relinquish the chair as required by the
planning planning Charter and invite the
vice chair councelor Humphries to
oversee the next three items councelor
Humphries will you take the chair
please thank you Council geffrey yes I
will take the chair and um we'll now go
to item s D which is DC oblique 20
oblique 055 95 the angel in 5 High
Street deham and I'll now invite the
case officer Alex Scott to introduce the
application to committee Alex
please uh thank you chairman yes if I
can just uh try and present my uh
presentation and hopefully that's uh
visible to all
n and slideshow from
beginning
that's working yes thank you very
much okay as um as mentioned by the um
the chairman this uh this application
sorry this site has two applications
relating the first is uh item 7D in your
papers which refers to um planning
permission and the second is item 7e
which refers to listed building consent
now we'll take the uh the application
for planning permission that's dc20
uh
0595 first and this is an application
for the change of use and extension of
the existing angel in Pub in High Street
deham uh to a 4bedroom
dwelling uh with a subsidiary amount of
uh retail uh or office space uh at
ground floor level so that is the
proposal this first uh slide uh shows
the loc of deham within the district for
the avoidance of Doubt to
all uh this next slide um shows the
approximate location of the site within
the
village this is a an aerial photograph
of the site and
surrounds a list of uh or planning
constraints map and I a site in question
is uh get my cursor up is here so the
pub itself is gray two listed well it
does affect the setting of this um
building to the North or collection of
buildings which are grade two star
listed so um of Greater importance in
the uh historic
listing and the site is within the deham
conservation area as indicated by
this
faint purple area
here the site is within the settlement
boundary of the village uh indicated by
the solid Blue
Line excuse me and the uh the Blue Area
here indicates uh environment agency
flood zone um flood zone two and three
uh which there is a higher probability
of of flood risk so uh those are the
major constraints on the
site
next uh slide is a extract from the uh
the neighborhood plan the deham
neighborhood plan uh showing uh
allocation proposals and uh planning
constraints and this next slide is uh
zoomed in on that previous plan and I've
circled the the site in yellow here and
um this approximately relates to the
constraints as previously
shown on the on the on the first slide
within the settlement boundary indicated
uh this uh this green line within the
conservation area this purple
line and um a constraint specific to the
uh neighborhood plan is the um is the
retail core of the village and the
relating policy uh Deb 13 and that is
indicated by this uh this purple area
and um important to note that the site
does lie uh outside of that uh that
retail call as as specified in the uh
the plan and um I've referred to um that
that issue in the uh in the report so
hopefully that is uh that is clear what
uh what policies we uh we should be
applying this next slide is the site
location plan uh submitted with the with
the application indicating the site in
red and all other land with within the
applicant's ownership and control edged
in blue
there this is the uh site layout plan as
proposed um so we have the existing Pub
here um the adjacent uh dwelling
house and High Street runs in this
location access to the site is through a
uh an arched access way into a rear
graveled Courtyard where there's
existing turning and parking
provision and the proposed alterations
you can see on this this plan are a
first floor rear extension to provide an
additional bedroom and a a glazed lean
to extension um which would replace an
existing flat roof extension which is
there and uh got some photographs of
that which I'll come on to
later
this is the uh the ground floor plan as
existing um the existing Pub um so we
can see the uh the bar area um backstage
areas the kitchen uh the conservatory um
public toilets and the the dining room
um in this area with stairs leading
upstairs and excuse me as uh as proposed
um we have um well the majority of the
ground floor is proposed to be converted
and extended to uh to the dwelling uh to
the
uh to the four-bedroom
dwelling and it would result in
a a loss of uh approximately uh
73% of the existing commercial floor
space available at ground floor level
all that would remain would be this area
here which which is proposed uh for uh
retail or an office as indicated on this
this plan and that is uh land use uh
Class E in the current uh classes
order within the rear existing gravel
Courtyard is proposed to be converted to
a domestic garden with uh parking Bays
allocated for uh both the dwelling and
the uh retail office space and as set
out in the report your officers consider
this is uh in accordance with um
existing uh
County Parking
standards uh this is the uh first floor
plan as uh existing uh showing the
existing domestic space associated with
the uh the pub so we have uh one two
three bedrooms and um this is the uh
historic Gallery which is referred to in
the report and by the uh the Heritage
officer uh
specifically and the floor plans as
proposed so um
we a few internal alterations a um
non-sweet bathroom to bedroom one more
storage space um a doorway to be um
created in the uh external wall of the
existing gallery and uh the creation of
a a first FL extension to provide a uh
an additional bedroom uh was referred to
as bedroom two on this
plan and we have the rear elevation as
existing um this is the adjacent uh
dwelling here and so the um the site in
question relates to this area
specifically and we have um the rear of
the dwelling this is the uh the arched
access to the gravel
Courtyard and the historic Gallery
referred to in this location and this is
the modern uh flat roof extension uh
which is proposed to be uh altered as
part of the application
proposal and here we have the uh
proposed rear elevation so the um
existing modern flat roof extension is
pro proposed to be altered and extended
um with a a glazed lean to extension and
this is the uh the two element of the
back um as you can see a very
contemporary design with the uh the
window design and that would be black
boarded and uh slate roof is proposed in
contrast to the uh the render and the
red tile of the existing
Pub then finally uh existing and
proposed side elevations and um as you
can see this is the modern
two-story extension ion um and
importantly um the proposed roof
structure would not adjoin the existing
uh restructure of the pub um it would uh
stand alone somewhat that's referred to
in the report I
believe uh onto some photographs this is
the uh front of the uh the angel taken
from High
Street and an alternative uh view there
looking back up towards the uh great two
Star Building in that
location and this is from the rear
Courtyard showing the arched access the
existing um modern flat roof extension
here and the historic
gallery and another view of that
stepping back and then of the adjacent
building to the opposite side there uh
for your information
that uh concludes the uh presentation
chair um now in terms of the
recommendation as said out in uh in your
papers um in the introduction
section an appeal against
non-determination has been lodged by the
applicant uh therefore uh your officer's
recommendation is uh to resolve uh puta
uh reasons for refusal upon which uh the
council would defend uh defend the
appeal so um the determination of the
application is uh now rather in the
planning inspectorates hands rather than
the local planning Authority and the
recommendation is uh um how how we are
to defend that appeal if that's clear um
hopefully it is thank you chair thank
you I think it is um so we will move on
to question from Members um and we'll go
alphabetically on this just to just to
keep it nice and clean so uh councelor
gold do you have any questions uh no
questions for me uh chair Council Guth
know you the W member do you have any
questions expecting that no thank you
okay councelor melon
please um yeah please chair um ju I'm
just trying to get my head around the
sequence of events here and if if the
officer could just clarify this so it
was refused by committee previously in
2015 or 2016 and then the planning
inspector allowed an appeal but nothing
has happened on that appeal or or or on
the work and now they're coming back
again is that is that what
happened um yes thank thank you
councelor melon uh yes just to clarify
that uh that previous application was
for uh the conversion of uh the pub as
was so the pub was Prett previously
larger than it was and that application
related specifically to the subdivision
to the house now that that house is
existing um as I've um or if I can go
back
to relevant slide just to illustrate
that
um just bear with me a moment
please so if that is uh showing uh for
you Council melon um the that that
previous application related to this
area of of the building specifically
um yeah that that is now a house um so
we recommended uh refusal as or we
refused the application indeed as uh as
a council That Was Then appealed and uh
our decision was overturned and that
that development has now been carried
out okay got you thanks for the
clarification no
problem thank you and moving on to
councilor mayor
please yeah thanks chair um a question
about I believe the pub is now an asset
of community value um correct me if I'm
wrong but that does that mean that the
community have got if it's sold have got
to be given um first chance to to
purchase the property if that's the case
how much weight can we put on that in
planning terms um I'll just jump in
there I'd like Mr depre please to answer
that on the Community Asset please yeah
very very very happy to Chairman yeah um
an asset of so if if it is registered as
an asset of community value um it well
what that means is that that fact is a
material consideration in plan in in a
planning decision however the the
registration does not require the owner
to sell to a community group or anybody
else who wants to buy they have right to
say no I'm not selling or um you know or
or I'm not selling to you or whatever
it's just it is a kind well yes I that's
all I think that's all I need to say I
mean I think I'm not being too
controversial if I say that that piece
of legislation uh has not I think a lot
of people
fought I've met people over the last 10
five or 10 years who thought it was free
compulsory purchase or at very least
compulsory purchase if they had the
money and it isn't so I don't know I I
mean that that that would be that's a
position Alex may need to add something
if he wishes to that thank you thank you
for the clarity and um Mr P G would you
like to jump in on that
one yes so uh in terms of the process
the uh being registered means that yes
essentially the public or Community
groups have an opportunity uh to come in
um in terms of the sale of the property
uh in terms of material considerations
for planning um the weight you give that
is actually at the discretion of members
um I would suggest that it demonstrates
the community interest in the uh
building and of course uh in terms of
policies of the past uh that are now
guidance in terms of retention of public
houses one of the tests of retention of
public houses is to understand the
community um will and uh in wanting to
retain that asset and I suppose you
could argue that being register Ed is
evidence of that will um but ultimately
it is a different and separate uh
process but it is given material weight
we don't tend to give it a lot of
material weight but members do and can
give it as much material way to say so
wish thank you all for your
comprehensive answers and I think we've
got a far better understanding of it now
councelor mayor thank you very much
that's that's very useful thanks uh
councelor Norris please
C Norris you have question sorry very on
the go slow this morning my laptop uh no
questions thank you okay councelor
Stringer please um yeah thank you chair
um just wanted to a question on the
timing um we we we have an appeal uh
going on this but as far as I can see
the dates uh the last neighborhood
consultation expiry date was was
something around the 25th of February so
Gathering it takes a couple of weeks to
get something to committee can I just be
uh appraised of the timing of the appeal
I take it the applicant has appealed
almost the day after the the day they
could have done thank you Alex
please um yes in terms of the timing I
mean um
the applicant uh should appeal after the
expiry date of um the application as as
I'm um understanding I may need to get
Ian to um clarify a little bit of this
but um yes I mean the application it
we're certainly beyond the
initial um end date for the application
the initial 8we date um That Was Then
extended by agreement uh between myself
and the applicant for uh revised
drawings um in an attempt to satisfy
Heritage concerns um as it turned out
those didn't but that's uh another issue
really but uh from my understanding we
are Beyond um we are beyond the point of
determination therefore the applic
applicant is within their rights to
submit an application for um
non-determination if I'm correct could I
get may I just come in quickly on one so
the the EXP date of the application is
the 26th of February um unfortunately I
don't have to hand exactly when the
appeal was made valid but it would have
had to been made valid uh after the 26th
of February so between the 26th and
today the appeal has been made valid um
not to try to elongate this conversation
but we have appeal in place and we have
a recommendation that takes that into
account and that is what is before
members
today I'm happy with that chairman I
don't think you need me to add anything
thank you Council Stringer happy with
the answer
yes chair yes chair thank you councelor
War boys
please yeah thank you chair um yeah
could I could I just come back to the
asset of community value um material
consideration I understand that if the
development um if it degrades the sort
of commercial
valab of a Community Asset then that
that becomes
um a matter for more um serious
consideration so we need to be aware of
that
long-term uh
viability
Alex uh yes chair thank you um yes I
mean it it certainly listed as a asset
of community value I've had that
confirmed by our um uh community team as
well in terms of uh whether that would
degrade the commercial viability long
term
um I think I think that's sort of a
matter of uh fact and degree of what you
know where you are in the in the current
climate um and um yeah I think I've said
little bit about this in the in the
report I mean we have a uh a viability
assessment uh submitted
um with the application uh from the
applicant and a a counter assessment by
the um by the by the Steering group the
community Steering group and uh yeah
those those have given um different
different values as I've as I've said
that in the report so yeah I think it's
just a matter of um timing and fact and
degree and uh the climate one is in at
the moment to how you would value uh
that property but um I'm afraid I'm not
an expert in uh in valuation yeah no
problem at all thank
you uh Mr goldi could you could you turn
your camera off please I know it's easy
sometimes we we select it on when we
don't mean to so if you could turn that
off that'd be fantastic thank you okay
I'm now going to ask the fact Mr Gold
Smith yeah if you just turn your camera
off thank you um I'll now ask the parish
council representative Jane bwin to
speak
please there have you got me yes I have
and welcome and thank you for attending
you've got three minutes to address the
committee just ready to start it we'll
be timed thank you okay ready let's go
in the 10 years since the current owners
purchased the angelin it's gone through
11 planning applications and eight
appeals what started with the loss of
the beer garden has culminated in an
application that will undoubtedly result
in the total and irreversible loss of
the only venue of its kind left in deham
the faithful application for change of
use granted on appeal in
2016 which we all strongly opposed never
saw the promised Community use delivered
which the applicant had assured the
resulting dwelling is currently on the
market for £650,000
the new application for change of use of
what's left of this once magnificent
Village Pub and designated Heritage
asset is not a benign application and
will Prejudice any possibility of it
remaining as a pub there are no social
economic or environmental benefits
associated with the proposal and it
would not result in sustainable
development it goes against an extensive
number of national and local planning
policies is significantly weighted to
residential with a small inadequately
serviced area and likely to attract a
business occupier and will not provide
anywhere near if at all the level of of
employment it once did there's no
evidence that the establishment was
marketed diligently or at a fair price
the independent valuation established a
market value £100,000 below the market
sale price accounts Pro the pub was
financially viable when the applicant
closed it in
2019 and a number of approaches were
made by investors including the local
community group willing to purchase at a
fair price and keep it running as a pub
the last approach was in January of this
year deham is a thriving core Village
and tourist destination rich in retail
facilities self-employment manufacturing
farming and top schools with an
award-winning neighborhood plan that
provides for considerable growth and
development of over the next 20 years
the loss of the chitry saw the Angel
become the main Community Hub 21 pages
of testimony supported our successful
ACV application and his evidence of the
depth of feeling in the community the
loss of this last principal Public House
in the village would negatively impact
the communities well-being in general
unnecessarily adding to feelings of
isolation exclusion and discrimination
impacting families and people with a
physical disability or without
transport it would be detrimental to
tourism and visitors and potentially
affect the economic viability of our
existing businesses this past year has
shown us all the importance and value of
local amenities assets services and
communities the angel in represents all
four and this Village needs this much
more than another three or four
bedroomed house we urge this committee
to note the objections from over 110
residents a community group our Council
and your own officers and refuse both
applications please do not allow this
financially driven proposal to eradicate
400 years of Irreplaceable history
Heritage and Community value thank
you the timing was perfect thank you
thank you so we'll go to questions from
uh from the members this time we'll
start with Council War boys please and
work our way up coun War
boys no questions coun no no questions
actually excellent presentation thank
you Council Stringer
no questions chair c
Norris no questions thank you counc
mayor nothing thank you councelor melon
no questions thank you very clear okay
and uh councelor Guth will come to you
later anyway so councelor G
please just a a a quick uh question
preface by um uh uh my thanks for what
was a very clear uh presentation and
those you you said this would be the
this was the only um Pub remaining in in
deham that's right
yes so you're muted I
think it's the only principal Pub it's
the largest Pub in deham the the other
one that remains is the woolpack which
is small No Beer Garden um and hasn't
been operating under covid because it
can only fit six people in under
restrictions sure okay thank you for
that thank you and uh thank you for your
presentation um if you could turn your
camera off that' be fantastic thank
you I'll now ask an objector to speak
which is Mr Alan cushion Mr cushion
please yes good morning I presume you've
got me okay yeah have welcome to the
meeting thank you for your attendance
you have three minutes uh to address the
committee and it will start as soon as
you're ready right I am speaking on
behalf of the Angel Community bid
Steering group to object to this
planning
application aside from the Heritage
aspects of the building works we believe
there are two main issues regarding the
applications the change of use of a
village pub to an alternative use should
not be permitted unless one or
reasonable efforts be made to sell or
let the property as a pub and two it is
shown to be not economically viable the
applicants have done neither of
these our statement of objection
included an independent professional
valuation of the property's market value
which showed that the initial sale price
was unrealistically high the community
group made an offer based on that
valuation when the angel came back onto
the market in October
2019 after being under offer at a
realistic price we we would have
certainly made an offer earlier and
perhaps there would have been more
interest from other buyers as well from
the pub accounts that we submitted as
part of our objection you will see that
when the pub was most recently trading
and even with the restrictions of a
short lease a beer tie and the paying of
a commercial rent to the owners it was
profitable for the land
lady no meaningful evidence to the
contrary has been provided
in addition to the social benefits the
angel employed the second highest number
of people in the High Street after the
co-op as deham is a growing key service
center planning decisions should retain
and guard against the unnecessary loss
of valued and viable facilities and
services prior to the formal process of
setting up a community benefit Society
or similar we have formed a group of
some 60 memb members we submitted with
our objection a list of the members who
have pledged money towards a bid for the
property from this base a wider public
offering with Community loans grants and
other support there is no doubt that a
viable fundraising exercise would be
possible a village the size and
importance of deam needs a pub at its
heart and the sheer number of people who
have objected shows a clear desire from
the community to see the angel reopen if
granted the application will mean the
permanent loss of the last facility of
this kind in the village and one that
has been serving the community for 500
years if refused the village can
continue to engage with the owners to
persuade them to sell to us or indeed
anybody else so the pub can reopen and
continue serving the
community thank you
thank you again excellent timing um
we'll use the hands up function I think
for this members if you have any
questions for um the
objector okay we have no questions uh
thank you for your attendance today and
if you could turn your video off that'
be much appreciated thank you I'm now
going to uh we in fact we don't have a
supporter or the applicant or agent so I
now ask the war member counselor um
Guthrie to speak speak Council Guthrie
please thank you very much chair um just
to put one or two things in perspective
I've obviously I always write things but
um the the Angel um when it was split
into two um it um it was as they've
described made into a house one side and
there was a substantial part of the
building left which is what this is um
and as we've heard from the um people
that have spoken already
there was a viability to that section
now Council of War boys asked about the
viability going forward now I don't want
to get confused between the viability of
the pub and the viability of this
proposal for which the officer said that
there was a 73% reduction of business
area with this proposal so the viability
of one room remaining um might be
councel War boy uh Focus or the
viability as a pub uh so I just wanted
to clarify that um so that people do
understand that as we've just heard the
pub as run in a smaller fashion was
successful so I don't want to repeat
much of what the parish council or the
objector has spoken about however the
loss of the Angel Public House which was
downsized brought distress to the
community and this application adds to
that
distress whilst swan a knowledges there
is a small Public House the woolpack
there isn't a suitable family-sized
public house or eery in deham when the
original Angel was downsized and split
into two the applicant had cited their
financial difficulties and the fact that
the cherry tree Public House was on
stream to be opened in any event that
property is now a Veterinary
practice that's the cherry tree from the
2011 census debam has approximately 1,7
households and of course the local and
surrounding Villages feed into deham for
shopping doctors hairdresses and the
like and the odd pint of beer planning
permission has been granted for 18
houses at one end of the village
recently and a further 54 will be
applied for at the other end of the
village not to mention various infill
housing which has been going on since
the
census the smaller Pub still named the
angel was run very successfully by two
successive land ladies and we have heard
heard how it was understood that the
latter one was unable to continue due to
possible restrictions and increased rent
which would prove unviable as the owners
had moved into the adjoining property
which they have converted into a
four-bedroom property and this was done
on appeal and that again was explained
earlier we've heard from the community
there is an active group of people with
appropriate funding who wish to purchase
the pub and run it as a proper Pub once
again and have applied for the
successful listing and an asset of
community value and we've heard the
reasons and and what an asset of
community value does but indeed it
demonstrates the the will of the people
with the economic situation having been
flawed by covid it is heartening there
is such a ground swell of support to
make this the real heart of debam and a
resounding success once again you are
asked to determine if enough evidence
has been provided to turn the remaining
part of this once magnificent grade two
listed building into living
accommodation with a small room for
retail and replace the rear
extension I would ask you to take great
regard to the Heritage officers views
this is a significant Heritage grade 2
listed building which needs to be save
from further
denigration the economic development
team feel the small area for business
would be unlikely to attract a business
let alone a viable one the previous
application split the pub into two was
refused by committee and although agreed
by an appeal inspector he made
particular reference to safeguarding the
remainder of the attached
property I would also ask if the
temporary partition that he referred to
in item 11 has been satisfactory
resolved to building in Heritage
standards it is sad that the applicants
although have engaged with the community
but they've decided not to have a
positive outcome to run the angel as the
once center of the village
I would ask you to look at the planning
officer's assessment and refuse this
application thank
you thank you Council Guthrie and we use
the hands up function please do we have
any questions for Ward member from
Members okay there are no questions
thank you councelor Guthrie we'll now
move to
debate um I'm going to open this up for
debate and uh we'll do alphabetically so
start with councelor ghou
please thank you uh very much uh chair I
have to say I I struggle to find any
Merit uh in in this
application um there's sort of two
principal points uh I wanted to make one
is that this seems to be the the
reduction in the commercial area seems
well might might have the motive
ascribed to it of creating a self
fulfilling prophecy and that if you
reduce the space by that that much that
indeed it's not going to be very
attractive uh to uh to a commercial um
business uh the second point which is
related is about the uh the value of the
pub as a pub to the community and I
think if there's one thing that we have
learned over the last uh 12 months or
more is how frequently pubs are cited as
uh the much missed sort of community
place where the community community can
gather uh and I think uh it would be
very sad if a if a settlement uh an
important settlement the size of deam is
left without um a a pub um of this
position in the village and also this
Heritage and and history I think that
would be very sad indeed I think I'm
right in saying that in terms of assets
of community value that actually pubs
are the most frequently uh listed uh
such asset I stand to be CED on that but
I think that that is the case um and I
think that demonstrates the place that
pubs play uh in a successful and
cohesive community and it would be very
sad If This Were Lost I say I can't see
I struggle to find any Merit in this
application uh particularly placed in
the in the planning history uh as
described uh earlier on which um doesn't
fill me or give me cause for any
confidence at all about um the the the
the intention motives that lie behind uh
the application so I won't have uh any
difficulty in following the officer's
advice uh on this thank you very much
chair thank you councelor moving to
councelor melon
please thank you chair um I don't have
much to add to what councel gold has has
said really um we know that pubs are
struggling and closing in many
communities but I would think that deham
is a you know a big enough place to
support a viable public house as a
business um it seems to me this is a
speculative application which is seeking
to monetize a Community Asset um there
is not much Merit in the proposals
except for um for the applicant um so
yes I'm I'm not not keen on this either
I I would be supporting the officer's
recommendations thank
you thank you councilor mayor
please chair I I really have nothing
more to add um I'm not surprised the
applicant isn't here to be honest uh
we've heard some excellent presentations
all of which were very informative um
they and they they really did um give us
the information I think we need to
support the um the officer's
recommendation and I'm happy to propose
uh that we do so thank you thank you uh
therefore we do have a proposer um I'm
looking for a second and we will
continue with debate but would anybody
like to second please looks like
councelor Stringer
yes chair uh more than more than happy
to Second this uh public houses do
become uh quite a centers of communities
and and if they're threatened in any way
you do tend to see communities get
mobilized which is precisely what we're
seeing here um our current policies
about retentions of public houses though
in villages um do somewhat lack uh the
ability to get the desired outcomes we
wish uh they almost become a race to the
bottom because we we we're not using
that policy here but we have a retention
of Public House policy that seeks to uh
preserve the last remaining one which is
fine but we tend to find the last
remaining one often is not the one that
it's most viable I go to the appeal
decision about viability and the appe
inspector quite rightly suggested that
the development in 2016 could go ahead
and the pub still remain viable and I
see absolutely no evidence to suggest
that this Pub would not be viable if it
were given half chance chair so uh
looking at all the documents have before
me I will wholeheartedly support the
officer's recommendation thank you
chair thank you uh let's continue with
the um so we do have a proposal in a
secondly we'll continue with councelor
Norris
please thank you Mr chairman uh well I
think it's pretty well all been said I
don't wish to repeat comments of my
colleagues other than I will just refer
to a couple of items in the report which
I think just about says it all uh at the
foot of page
357 The Proposal would lead to the
dimunation of an established Village
facility which may pre introduce its
longer term future as a community and
tourism asset and contribute to the to
the rural economy and on page 393 the
proposal for the conversion is not
supported by Economic Development so I
have no hesitation in supporting the
recommendation to refuse thank you thank
you councelor warboys
please yes I think um uh people have
have
gone had some excellent presentations uh
I think there's a couple of points um I
think deam is a very attractive Village
and the street scene would be unaltered
uh and I but I think very often it's
possible to look at um the great two
listed buildings just in terms of their
external qualities here it's the
internal qualities that are very
important and it's the permanent changes
to the ground floor will cause harm to
the architectural and historic interest
these permanent changes to the ground
floor I think also affect its viability
as as any kind of a commercial IAL
operation uh reduction of uh I think it
was over 70% of the floor space it it
just wouldn't be possible to function as
as um as a public house and uh the
selage would wouldn't really work either
for the bar um I think the presentations
have already talked about the the
enormous value of this building as a pub
in in a in a Vibrant Community and and
the there's a quote somewhere I said the
best thing to do with a pub is to keep
it as a
pub thank you um I don't um think we
need to go to the second stage of debate
unless you want to say anything else
just raise your hand if that's the case
anyone okay brilliant so um yeah my own
thoughts then um I thought the
presentation by Jan Balwin and
uh cushion basically cemented everything
that's within the recommendations for
refusal they were good presentations and
certainly brought things to life um my
point on this one is that this would be
a total and irreversible loss of a
Community Asset I a public house and I
don't think we can let that happen it's
a principal Pub as well which is really
important to the community so much so
that the community actually put an offer
in to buy it um as a Community Asset now
obviously and we've heard from the legal
uh representative there's no requirement
for the actual owner of the building to
sell it as such that's entirely up to
him um but it does demonstrate the
community will and I think that has got
weight of maintaining this as a public
house I think uh councilor gold is right
on the reduction of 73% of that business
use or commercial use and actually when
you look at that office which could be
an office um it's positioned within the
the um the the residents I guess um it's
not really viable but I'm not in that
business so it's just my perception of
it so don't be guided by that um but be
guided by the mppf so it's quite clear
really in parah uh 84 and 92 as
described within the recommendations for
refusal that where possible we should
maintain these public houses and I think
that's right on the historic side of it
I do think that this does affect it and
it says there it's a medium uh a medium
uh uh risk so therefore for that reason
I'd refuse as well so I'm with the
proposer in the second on this one and
uh I'll probably in fact almost
certainly be voting to refuse um I'll
now ask the chief planning officer area
planning manager to summarize the
proposal on the table before we go to
the
vote thank you chairman um I think it's
I'm not going to read the whole thing
out because it's quite long uh so your
recommendation is uh to have ped reasons
for refusal uh on the basis that an
appeal has uh come forward um so the
recommendation therefore provides two
reasons for that refusal uh on page uh
372 of your papers and
373 um and the essentially we are
looking at the employment policies um
being offended and uh with reference to
the uh deam neighbor plan and the second
part of the refusal is is in resp
respect of the historic significance and
the harm uh being uh conducted in
respect of this proposal um I could read
it out word to word but I think if
you're okay J I will leave it that it is
as per paper yeah I think so everybody
is happy with that has got access to
that proposal on page 372 373 uh please
raise your hand if you haven't or can't
read
it yeah then I'm happy thank you uh
Chief planning officer area manager yeah
thank you very much and ask the
governance officer to conduct the
electronic
vote thank you chair um members if you
could please go to the modern. goov app
and go to today's agenda and in the top
right hand corner you will see the plus
sign and click on that and then the
subsection for voting will come up the
vote will be halfway down the screen um
and will be in a light blue
color
thank you chair all votes have now been
received and as detailed in the um
planning Charter the ward member cannot
vote so it is seven votes for which is a
unanimous vote of me members on the
committee thank you that is carried is a
refusal um we'll take a 5 minute break
um just to stretch your legs so please
just five minutes and we come back in
where we'll look at item seven Echo
thank
you
welcome back and uh we're now going to
move on to agenda 7e which is DC oblique
20 oblique 055 96 the angel in 5 High
Street deum Stow market suffk and I'll
now invite the case officer Alex Scott
to introduce the application to the
committee Alex please
uh thank you chairman if I can again uh
present my
presentation and again hopefully
everyone can uh see that start the
slideshow from the
beginning now this is uh an application
for listed building consent um item 7e 7
echo in the papers uh application
reference DC
20596 um
and we're again at the angel in five
High Street deham and the application
seeks listed build and consent for uh
internal and external alterations and
extensions in order to facilitate the uh
change of use to a dwelling with the
subsid subsidiary retail and office
space at ground floor level as uh you
previously considered in the uh in the
planning application um before this uh
before this item
and um just onto the presentation again
uh the site location of debam within the
district uh the location of the Angel
approximately within the
village and aerial view of the site and
area uh the constraints map so we're
dealing with a grade two listed building
as indicated in Orange here and it
affects the setting so significance of
uh a grade two star listed building
indicated in red here immediately to the
north and um the other planning
constraints as well
um and those of the uh neighborhood plan
uh similar and as before we're outside
of the retail core as indicated in that
in that
plan uh again we have the site location
plan area indicated in red all other
land in the applicants ownership and
control indicated in
blue this is the proposed site layout
plan so externally uh what is proposed
is a a rebuilding of the existing modern
single story flat roof extension to the
rear uh principally and uh the erection
of a first
floor um resultant two-story extension
modern character uh to provide a a
bedroom primarily at uh first floor
level and then a a glazed lean
to um roof extension to the existing
flat roof extension to the rear of the
building uh beneath the historic Gallery
as we've already
seen and uh this is the ground floor
plan as existing um laid out as the The
Pub bar and dining room and um ancillary
toilets and backstage kitchen and
Conservatory bin
store and the proposed ground floor plan
um mostly the uh that of a dwelling um
living room dining room kitchen and this
area here uh approximately
um 26% of the total ground floor area um
to
be uh given over to retail or office
space as we've previously heard as well
and uh this area of the of the existing
Courtyard to be laid out as as Garden in
association with the proposed dwelling
and the four um parking spaces to be
retained within that area um again in
accordance with suffk advisory parking
standards uh we
believe and the first floor plan as
existing um so we have the existing flat
roof of the modern extension here um at
first floor level we have the historic
Gallery it contains an existing bedroom
and we have existing kitchen facilities
in this area and two existing bedrooms
and a bathroom uh in these
areas and they proposed alterations uh
looking at uh the erection of partitions
to uh provide um wardr space and um and
on Suite bathroom to bedroom one uh the
conversion of bedroom 3 to um
uh to a um yeah I think that's a a
dressing room there and um the creation
of a an access and the existing external
wall of the historic gallery to access
the uh proposed bedroom extension the uh
first floor extension to the to the
building and um these these areas
um um to remain pretty much un altered
as there as the two bedrooms and
bathroom in this
area and uh the existing rear elevation
showing the existing modern extension
which is proposed to be altered and
extended and we have here the
Contemporary designed two-story element
of the extension proposal and the glazed
link the glazed lean
to uh roof extension uh being most
uh most prevalent there
and the existing side
elevation and proposed side elevation
again showing the two story element and
its Detachment from the historic roof
space and again the uh photographs from
High
Street and the
rear Courtyard for you
and as said out in in the report uh we
have uh again excuse me specifically for
this uh application for listed building
consent uh uh the planning inspector
have received a application for appeal
against
non-determination so again um the
officer recommendation is for members to
agree um posative reasons for uh refusal
uh upon which the council will defend uh
the appeal and those relate specifically
to to the alterations to the listed
building as we are just dealing with a
application for listed building consent
here as part of this uh particular
application uh thank you chair that
concludes the
presentation thank you Alex we'll now
move on to questions for members uh
please use the hands up for this one who
wants to go
first okay I can see no questions just
give you a couple more seconds
in that case we're going to move on to
the parish council representative which
again is Jane bwin hello
Jane yeah thank
you
this is the legal advisor I can't see
the lady's name amongst the
attendees thank you I think it's fine
it's probably going to be very similar
to the last one anyway so okay if
everybody's happy I am going to move on
do we have the obor which is Alan
cushion uh yes I am I haven't prepared
anything specific to do with the uh to
this side of things
but I have can just give you a couple of
comments yeah again you've got three
minutes we welcome your your
comments okay then just looking uh the
uh north side of the Angel is now up for
sale and looking at the sale brochure
for that part of the building it does
not appear that they've retained the
Heritage aspects of the the building um
it's it's a very modern um
interior uh secondly that
uh as a pub the features such as the
huge Engel Nook which is in the current
pub with its witches marks and other
historic features uh that is available
for the public to view if the planning
application goes ahead and it's turned
into uh a residence then obviously this
these features are lost and no way that
you can protect them uh for future
Generations uh lastly the comment that's
been made before uh the best way to
retain a historic building is in its
original use which for hundreds of years
it's been a pub and I feel it should
stay that way thank you thank you very
much um again using the hands up
function do we have any questions uh for
Mr
cushion
okay there are no questions thank you
for
attending my pleasure uh sadly we don't
have a supporter or the applicant or
agent so we'll now ask the ward member
to speak which is councelor Guffy
councelor Guffy please um thank you very
much counc before we go on sorry uh Mr
Carmichael you'd like to say
something or um B just before your point
I was just going to say because I have
received from the parish council they
did send their statement
um through to me beforehand and I
believe that that covered both points in
what they said the first time round so
just to clarify that I believe um before
we moved on no thank you as long as long
as there's nothing additional in there
um then I'm happy that we continue
councelor
Guth yes thank you very much I mean
really um the the group saving uh the
angel and wanting to purchase it have
said really all there is to say about
this and the Heritage side of things I
did mention in my um statement that I
was wondering and worried whether a
partition that had been put in place as
a temporary partition whether that's to
sufficient building reg standards and
the Heritage satisfaction and so on that
basis um obviously um there is a query
there but that's all I wish to say thank
you thank you I do you have any
questions again using the hands up
facility for councelor
Guffy
okay there are no questions we're now
going to move to debate so I'll open up
the item for debate and we'll start um
with councilor War boys please and move
way up alphabetically councelor War
boys thank you chair yes I I think um a
lot of what we said about the first the
previous application applies to this one
uh I think very concerned these are
permanent changes to the interior of an
historic building um and in turn the
will affect the long ter its long-term
commercial viability to clarify as a
public house um so I would support the
officer's recommendation to
refuse the planning
application thank you councelor um do I
take it your making a proposal or not I
I I will put that as a proposal yes
thank you can we have a second
please councelor
Stringer thank you chair um yeah just
wanted to say just a few words if I may
I'm happy to Second this but I'd like
some guidance from the officers about
actually including another reason for
refusal uh if you look under the
recommendation at the bottom of
paragraph one it says furthermore there
are no public benefits associated with
the proposal development which would
outweigh the harm actually there is a
public disbenefit from approving this
either the public will never be able to
see the historic core of that building
again and enjoy it as a community
building so actually I agree with that
statement but I'd actually like to
consider another statement that says in
fact there is a public disbenefit from a
from changing its fundamental use uh and
that is in Heritage terms because
Heritage just isn't about the fact that
the beam is still there or the window is
still still there for it to be part of
the public Consciousness the public have
to see it
um so frankly I think I'd like that to
be addressed within the conditions if it
possibly could chair apart from that
happily agree to to Second this thank
you for the proposal and the seconding
um I'll ask uh Mr to come in
when uh this is unusual I've not come
across this idea before if I'm perfectly
honest um does it cause a dis yeah I'm
not denying there's a a disadvantage in
fact and quite agree with the counselor
when I read that uh recommendation and
and considering what we've considered I
would definitely agree with the with the
member in terms of the uh
disadvantage however um in terms of the
nppf and uh list of building legislation
uh we are needing to balance public
benefit against the harm what we're
trying to identify here is the harm is
denial of the public seeing the element
of the list of building an element
harm I would struggle with defending
that because of course the opposite
argument would be that they could just
close down the building and deny the
public access within their own right um
this is a commercial premises it isn't a
public park or something that has uh a
right of access for the public um that
overrides all other issues I'm not sure
if Ian can help me out any further on
that but I would be probably very
cautious to introduce that on the basis
that the public public right could be
removed I think I I entirely see the
point through you Mr chair I entirely
see John's point that it's we we do come
across this from time to time that there
is a situation where in real life the
public very much appreciate a building
but in fact is under private ownership
and if there is access to it it could be
stopped tomorrow um or or you know
things could be done to to restrict the
way in which the public you know even
can see it sometimes so I think that
would um yeah I mean I yes I I agree
with I I I get entirely get counselor
string as point but I I would concur
with John's
caution thank you and I agree with all
three of you actually um but I've just
read the recommendation and it goes
furthermore there are no public benefits
associate with the proposed development
which would outweigh the harm identified
I think it sort of captures it but I do
get your point councelor Stringer it
could be clearer but it is where it is I
think there's enough in recommendation
in my honest opinion but we'll continue
debate uh councelor Norris
please thank you Mr chairman um well
really nothing further to add um I
totally agree with the sentiments
expressed by Council warb and I will be
supporting the recommendation thank
you thank you and councilor
mayor CH no not not a lot to add other
than
um the harm to the building I do
struggle with the design I struggle with
the close boarding of the rest of the
buildings rendered so now we've got a
proposal for close boarding um that
seems to be in congruous and and and
that that is is the harm that's
identified by the Heritage team so no I
see no public benefit and I see do see
the harm they've identified so I will be
supporting the
motion thank you uh we're now going to
move on to councilor melon
please uh yeah thank you chair um not
much to add I mean I think we have to
weigh these proposals up carefully but
um as the Heritage off officer has said
you know what is proposed will
compromise the building's Heritage value
it has impacts on the architectural
character and the proposed extensions in
Congress and assertive so I mean it's to
me it's just pretty open and shut case
so um i' would be certainly supporting
refusal thank you councilor ghou
please thank you chair as others have
said very little very little to ad I I I
totally uh agree with the point being
made by councelor Stringer and I
understand the reasons why it can't be
uh included but it's a Pity but it
doesn't mean that the point isn't isn't
right and valid uh all this is done
really is uh deepen my conviction that
the previous decision we took was
absolutely right and whilst the you know
there is a a point about responsibility
for Heritage and while someone may own
uh own a building as a as an asset my
view they're also owning the
responsibility uh to look after and
preserve that Heritage and I have to say
that responsibility hasn't been uh very
obvious in either of these applications
but I shall be supporting uh the The
Proposal thank you thank you um I don't
think there's a need to go to the second
round debate we do have a proposer and a
second um my own thoughts uh it's all
about the Heritage it's all in my
opinion captured pretty much in 3.5 of
page 443 where it talks about the build
the minimal attachment to the to the
main listed building Etc so I think
there's enough evidence in there on
historical uh reasons uh to refuse it so
I will also be voting that way
I'll now ask the chief planning officer
to summarize the proposal on the table
before we go to a vote
please thank you um so the
recommendation is on page uh 445 of your
papers uh the it is for res resolving to
refuse uh list of building consent um
and obviously the appeal has come
forward and so therefore these are the
reasons that we would put on members
behalf uh for refusal and defending of
that appeal um essentially the uh reason
for refusal is laid out there in terms
of we are saying that this would be
harmful uh in respect of the important
uh list of building character um without
uh public benefit to outweigh the harm
that's been identified in the proposals
for the extension and uh various other
works uh and on that basis we have
sought to refuse it on policies uh FC
101 sorry 1.1 um CS 5 hb1 hb3 hb4 and
deon's policy on historical Assets in
terms of deam uh policy number 18 as
well as various paragraphs of the nppf
in respect of the historic uh
significance and I will leave that with
members thank
you oh sorry saw your hand up sorry oh
sorry thank you chair um I just wanted
to confirm following um seconding from
Council Stringer that Council Stringer
still did wish to Second following the
guidance that um he was seeking from Mr
pman GN officers yeah yeah happy happy
to go with the guidance uh if not
slightly disappointed thank you
counselor chair if you're happy I will
conduct the electronic vote yes please
thank you chair so if members could
please go to the modern. goov app in the
system and please go to today's
agenda the and go to the plus sign in
the top right hand corner the and click
on the plus sign and go to the
subsection on voting SL attendance the
vote is now in progress and it's showed
in a light blue color and it will be
quite near the bottom of the page so you
may need to scroll down thank
you
thank you chair all votes have now been
received and as before um taking out
Council G's vot as the board member as
she is not allowed to vote under the
planning Charter um that is seven votes
for so is
unanimous thank you that is carried
refusal uh before we move to 7c again
we'll take a five minute stretch just so
we can sort everything out in
preparation of that uh of that agenda
point
see you back in five
minutes
uh welcome back we're now going to move
on to agenda 7c which DC oblique 20
oblique
04987 anchor storage IR Road Kenton Stow
Market before we do that Mr payman G
please yes thank you chairman um just a
bit of clarification in respect to the
report before members um just looking at
uh page 247 and paragraphs 4.3 and
4.4 um it comes across potentially that
there's the implication that the nppf is
part of the local plan part of the
development plan um just to make sure
we're very clear here that the nppf is
obviously not part of the development
plan it is a uh significant material
consideration uh that we give material
weight too um but we just it's just the
way that the those two paragraphs are
worded uh we didn't want there to be a
misunderstanding that could be picked up
later so on that basis I'm sure members
are very aware uh but the nppf is not uh
the part of the development plan
policies before you it is a material and
separate consideration I hope that it's
just a a technical matter we needed to
raise thank
you y thank you for the
clarity okay I'll n the um case officer
which she again is Alex Scott to
introduce the application to the
committee
Alex uh thank you chair and yes
apologies for members I did uh draft
those uh sections of the paragraph So
apologies that that uh wasn't that clear
but thank you to the uh area planning
manager for uh clarifying that right if
I can just
uh my presentation up hopefully that is
now showing and I'll
begin the slideshow
presentation so this is um item 7 C in
the papers application uh reference dc20
4987 at uh anchor storage uh I Road in
Kenton and the application seeks outline
planning permission um with matters of
access to be considered for the erection
of uh up to 30 two dwellings 32
dwellings following demolition of uh the
existing storage buildings now as set
set out in your papers um this
application follows a a similar um
proposal which was considered and uh
refused uh by Committee in February uh
2020 and um I'll come on to some of the
uh comparisons uh uh in the presentation
uh a bit further
on and for the avoidance of doubt this
is the location of Kenton within the
district uh the location of the site the
approximate location of a site within
the uh
Parish an aerial view of the site and
area so we have uh anchor storage here
and the existing buildings and uh excuse
me and uh some adjacent uh industrial
and farm buildings to the South uh the
main body of the village uh extending
away from the site to the to the the
Northwest and this is a a closer
view and the planning
constraints uh so we are uh outside of
the settlement boundary as
uh as delineated in the uh both the
existing and the emerging
um uh development plans um which
commences uh approximately here
um and the site is uh shown as being
potentially contaminated so
um some attention to uh land
contamination assessment and uh
mediation um it's uh is uh likely
necessary as part of the um as part of
The Proposal
and um conditions attached if we're
maned to
approve um the site affects the setting
of a grade two listed building sycar
Sycamore Farm to the uh to the south of
the site a public right of way public
foot path runs through the site
connecting into the existing uh Network
across the fields to the to the
East and part of the site lies within
environment agency flood zones two and
three as indicated on our constraints
maps and um yes so those are the
principal uh
constraints and this is an excert from
the emerging joint local plan which
shows Kenton as a uh a hamlet settlement
and you may be able to see the proposed
settlement
boundary in the plan and the site lies
outside of that plan um again the flood
zone indicated um taking in a little bit
of the uh the back of the site there um
so the emerging plan um bit of
information of direction of travel um
identified as a hamlet meaning uh uh
unsuited for large development but could
potentially accommodate some infill
development for
residential and these Maps show uh
pedestrian connections and links to
deham the nearest uh larger settlement
um by uh by Road Road sorry this side
and uh pedestrian connections that
side uh this is the site location plan
provided with the
application and the indicative uh layout
so the proposed means of access would be
via the
existing commercial access to the to the
site and we have the 32 dwellings
um um indicatively shown um as as
matters of of layout Landscaping scale
and appearance are presently um reserved
we're only considering detailed matters
of of access and and principle indeed as
part of this outline application uh to
be
clear and uh the the rear of the site is
shown to uh be given over to public open
space um which would
uh um double and include for a flood
risk uh attenuation Basin a surface
water drainage attenuation Basin but uh
as set out in the report um there are
some question marks about the um excuse
me proposed location of that uh that
Basin as it would fall within the uh the
flood risk area the um uh flood risk uh
areas two and three as uh as identified
on the constraints plan and by the
environment
agency and this is just a closer um view
of the uh of the layout
indicative and the surface water
drainage plan uh provided with the
application um but as you'll see in the
report some question marks have been
raised uh about the uh about the how fit
for purpose this this plan would be by
the uh suffer cada Council uh lead local
flood
Authority and for comparison we have the
uh the layout as previously considered
and refused um reference DC 19
4553 um that was in February
2020 and compared to the current
indicative layout uh as you can see
pretty similar um just with uh uh Less
in terms of uh bunding screening to the
South um with uh additional access um
proposed along there but uh pretty much
the same
there um as as per the your officer
recommendation um nine uh reasons for
refusal are given um as set out in the
uh the report uh unsustainable location
loss of employment land insufficient uh
flood risk
information
um no on-site affordable housing
proposed harm to the setting of the
listed building um
insufficient ecology information
provided insufficient noise assessment
um with concern to the Future am
amenities of future occupants in
relation to commercial activities uh
immediately to the
South and we believe the application has
failed to demonstrate uh a high standard
of design can be
achieved um with uh relation to those uh
potential noise and disturbance impacts
and the uh the location of the uh uh
drainage basin which has uh yet to be
confirmed um by uh the applicant and our
uh our consules
um that concludes the presentation
hopefully the recommendation is clear
thank you
chair thank you Alex very clear so let's
move to questions from Members please um
if you use the hands up facility and
I'll go through as your hands come
up okay councelor War boys
please yeah I I I just want to clarify a
little about the uh flood zone
assessment uh the environment agency
says it does not take into account
climate change
data uh so the environment agent has not
had enough information I I I just want
to confirm that
um the maps you use in the slide and on
the the local plan do take into the
climate do take into account climate
change data or there uh should there be
a further line on that showing extent
further extensive
flooding Alex please
um yes indeed uh now as I understand the
um AR constraints Maps as as I've
presented to you there um uh do not
fully take into account uh the uh uh in
the event of climate change adding to
that that flood risk and um the one of
the reasons for refusal um I believe
reason for is requesting further
information from the applicant um in
order to demonstrate that and um yes we
we we need that additional
information um from the applicant um in
order to be suitably informed um as what
our consules the environment agency
local lead flood
Authority um so we so we have a um a
better informed um we have the
information we need to uh make a make a
more reasonable uh um view on the on the
proposed layout and where the
attenuation Basin has gone but but yeah
so to your question C War boys those
flood maps uh I do not believe um take
fully into
account but John G yes thank you uh the
maps we have uh shown are the uh the
actual zones of flood zone one and two
sorry two and three uh ultimately
climate change Maps layered on top um
and there are various layers um because
climate change is is taken within
different year groups and so there would
be multiple layers need to be added on
top uh which actually visually would
make it quite confusing because you need
to go through one to the other um and
it's obviously the climate change in
itself doesn't uh in the modeling that
the environment agency does and so on uh
doesn't always necessarily mean um
certain Maps expand significantly there
are different variations of what that
may mean however for the purposes of uh
this exercise the basic layer map which
is what we've got in respect of uh flood
zone 2 and three adequately shows um
members in our opinion that the part of
the site will be within the flood zone
and that part of the site that is in the
flood zone is the area they're
indicating for an attenuation Basin now
there's a couple of question marks
around that as Alex has detailed because
how can an attenuation surface water
drainage system work effectively if you
have a flood event occurring at the same
time um now the question is this is an
outline we can deal with that later well
not quite because if you have to move
the attenuation Basin up into the site
will it then work will how will that
affect the layout can you in principle
squeeze X many houses onto this site
with that kind of constraint and in this
case there are other constraints that
Alex has detailed not least its
association with the business next door
the continuation of that business so
there's a lot of constraints here that
that really questions the principle of a
possible layout that is
demonstrated and um indicatively
certainly the layout presented to us
today doesn't demonstrate good quality
design and layout because of those
constraints but we haven't had nothing
given to us that would otherwise
demonstrate this number could be
achieved successfully in principle
against those constraints so it's a
combination of those considerations but
going back to the point no climate
change isn't on there and we're not
going to I don't think we need to dwell
on this but climate change probably
would mean it looks a little worse than
it is most likely but for the purposes
of our exercise we're happy and content
that the flood zone two and three are
clearly shown as conflict in in context
of this
application okay thank you very much
thank you thank you to the officers for
the clarity uh there are no other hands
up so we are going to move now to the
parish council representative which is
Mr Chris Goldsmith Mr Goldsmith hi there
good morning uh you have three minutes
to address the committee will be timed
and thank you for your attendance thank
you um firstly I'd like to cover off a
issue around transparency in the meeting
held the previous application a formal
invitation was applied to the applicant
and it was within the agenda that he was
attending at the last application uh a
letter was delivered to all the
households in the village uh the
applicant was approached read changes to
the application to solute solution the
refusal notice that was issued they
responded back with the information on
the changes a virtual meeting was called
via posters and an email to the Village
um and the agenda did not include the um
applicant to speak at the
meeting no formal invitation was offered
to the
applicant on the evening of the meeting
the applicant
joined he is not a resident
or on the register of
Voters he said that he wanted to address
the meeting and if I look at n legal
topic six um this was not um as a
non-resident Smith can can I just jump
in are we talking about a parish council
meeting here or we talk a parish meeting
right okay is it relevant to what we're
doing right now um I believe so because
I want to be transparent with this okay
all right let continue uh and we'll just
add on 20 seconds please Robert thank
you all right um the applicant was asked
to leave and um no participant at the
meeting actually spoke for the person to
stay um I will move off now into the
main uh
information it is correct that um and we
agree Kenton is a hamlet there are 89
houses in Kenton and the these 32 now
would increase the houses by
36% which is a substantial number to
increase by if we look into transport
the application um cites a daily bus
service to Stow Market there is no daily
bus service to Stow Market the only uh
bus service that exists is via the high
suffer Community Bus and that runs a
service every Thursday and sporadically
to elsewhere which does ser as Kenton if
we look at um a previous application
that came into the village in the last
few weeks which is heard by a planning
committee it was for little ows on I
Road uh there was a refusal of um
permission for that and part of the
refusal reads the provision of a new
dwelling in this Countryside location
away from essential facilities would
involve Reliance on the private motorc
car with no benefits resulted from other
strands of sustainable development to
outweigh the harm created in this
application we've got 32 new
houses I'm gonna ask you to summarize we
are at three minutes I'm sorry that's
okay and so uh for that reason there are
32 reasons based on that previous
application to to refuse and that we
seek that the council supports the
refusal as suggested thank you thank you
very
much apologies chair you're on mute yeah
thank you it's sticky button um so we'll
move on to questions for the Paris
Council repres use the uh hands up Cy
please if you have any
questions
okay they're on on uh Mr Gold Smith
thank you very much for your attendance
today uh if you could turn your
microphone off when you finished and
also your video thank
you okay we don't have an objector or
supporter so I ask the agent and
applicant speak Mr Philip cobal and
Steven
Brit and gentlemen you have three
minutes to go committee please let me
know when you're about to start I'm
ready thank you chair good morning
everyone uh the following comments refer
directly to the committee report
recommending refusal of this application
the site is no more remote from local
services and public transport than the
Crown Chicken Factory site at wbr where
the council recently granted planning
permission for 80 dwellings the officer
report for that application States and I
quote the 2 and 1 half mile drive to the
nearest services and public transport at
harston was an acceptable distance
Kenton to deham is the same distance as
W bre to harston consequently if the
Redevelopment of the Crown's Chicken
side at w bre for housing is considered
to be a sustainable location then the
same must apply to the Anchor storage
site the removal of modern hgvs from
unsuitable rural roads and the provision
of affordable housing or a commuted sum
represent significant public benefits no
development is to take place on the
small part of the site that is within
flood zone 2 which in living memory has
never been anywhere near flooding and is
15 M that's 50 ft above the drainage
ditch level at the southern end of
Kenton surface water drainage is a
matter which can be dealt with by a way
of planning
condition the council's policies which
protect employment land are out of step
with the government's planning policies
and objectives this is illustrated by
the changes at to permitted development
which enable offices to be converted to
dwellings without planning
permission the affordable housing
contribution will be a commuted some
rather than on-site provision when the
previous application was considered by
the committee councilors suggested that
affordable housing should not be
approved in areas without public
transport the commuted sum can be
controlled by section 106
obligation the replacement of large and
ugly warehouses with well-designed
housing will enhance the setting of The
adjacent listed and almost derelict
Sycamore
Farmhouse there has been no change in
the ecology report was since ecology
report was produced all the buildings at
the site are still in use nothing has
changed which would encourage Wildlife
onto the
site future occupants of the dwellings
would not be affected by noise or
disturbance from adjoining land uses as
the fields to the north and east and the
Redundant agricultural buildings to the
South are all part of Sycamore Farm in
summary I feel very let down by the Baba
mids planning department as it was only
through their initial contact and their
Keen interest in our Brownfield site for
housing that we are here now in short I
feel both their former senior planning
officer and their Economic Development
officer have misled us we have spent
nearly £50,000 on this project to date
this includes over £10,000 in your
planning fees alone and a further
£10,000 during the last year in various
fees and surveys for this
resubmission finally not only did the
local Parish meeting twice vote in favor
of the development but this housing
provision is precisely what the
government and prime minister were
wanting when their build build build
initiative was announced last year thank
you for your time today uh I or my agent
are happy to answer any technical
questions thank you Mr Brit uh for your
uh for your presentation uh we will move
on to questions from counselors so uh
please use the hands up facility to let
me know if you want to ask a
question there are no questions uh Mr
Brit thank you for attending um if you
could please turn off your microphone
and your video and we'll continue with
the with with the meeting thank you very
much thank
you I'm now going to ask the ward member
to speak which again is councelor
Guthrie councelor Guthrie please thank
you very much indeed chair the business
of anchor storage has been running for
many years and as we've seen the site is
quite large with storage facilities
adjacent to other farm buildings on one
side and a ribbon development of houses
on the
other there are numerous statements and
letters from the applicant and agent as
to why this site was originally put
forward in a call for
sites that in itself does not give
planning permission just the opportunity
to look and see if the site is suitable
for development times have moved on in
any event through debate and
conversations at mids suffk district
council with the policy team this site
and others in Kenton were deemed to be
unsuitable for development The Joint
local plan which admittedly is at Red 19
stage does not include this site and
even before the application was put
forward the information that the site
was not clear was not suitable was
clearly
available The Joint local plan is
designating Kenton Hamlet status which
allows small scale infill
growth reading all the
evidence and recent evidence from both
the applicant in the agent I do
understand their anxieties and
frustration
over where we are
now I believe it was intended to
relocate the business but at present we
don't have any evidence of this but
maybe that's not a planning
reason at a recent meeting of the parish
council discussions took place and
whilst there were one or two who felt
houses available for local workers would
be beneficial the majority voted against
the proposal of such a large housing
estate in this rural
location I don't wish to take each part
of the application and dissect it and
Alex has summed up all the reasoning as
to why this application should be
refused the site itself is embedded in
our rural community and the road to
deham is as pointed out by the applicant
2.3 miles miles away it is a tortuous
narrow unlit route with no foot paths or
verges to speak of and there is only one
bus a week I do understand there are
lorries coming to down there and
obviously if the housing estate was
built the lorries would would be
reduced we have a 7.67 land Supply and
try as I might I cannot see a good and
positive reason to recommend an urban
housing estate in this rural
location I do see that the applicant has
the opportunity to go to appeal should
members be minded to be refused
thank
you thank you um move on I just want to
go back one actually to to the
applicants um comments and I'm going to
ask Alex really I
noticed it was it was muted that um that
pre-advice was sought but yet on the
application sub uh pre-application
advice it says no I'd like to just
clarify that please
Alex um yeah chair on this particular
application uh no pre application advice
was sought okay thank you um let's move
on to questions for the ward uh member
so hands up please if you wish to ask
any
questions there are no questions thank
you councel kri thank you we're now
going to move to debate uh and I'll open
up this item for debate this time we'll
go alphabetical so we start with Council
goal please
thank you uh thank you chair um again I
I find the officer report very clear and
I I also um value the uh the comments
made by councelor gathri which I I
thought were uh very reasoned uh and and
balanced um I little to say about this
I'm I'm um I find the reasons for
refusal uh
adequate and convincing and that's all
I've really got to say about this uh the
reasons for for uh refusal um seem
absolutely right to me
thanks thank you moving on to councilor
melon
please uh yeah thank you Mr chairman um
yeah it's an interesting one I I know
this Village quite well um I go through
it occasionally and um I know this site
but
um if it a site is in commercial
usage uh it it's it to me doesn't fit
really the the idea of a Brownfield site
it's not a redundant site uh if it's
currently being
used um but the other thing is just to
look at all the the statut and internal
conso T's I've never seen I don't think
so many either holding objections or
concerns about an application I think
we've got eight or nine amongst all the
different departments and statutory
consult tees I mean you know we we see
these applications uh regularly with
with perhaps one or two I don't think
I've ever seen that many before and that
does really sort of ring alarm bells for
me um so um I'm certainly not very much
in faor of this proposal but I'll listen
to the the other members and the
debate
thank you uh moving on to councelor
Mayor
please thanks chair
um I think the the officer's report is
very clear and I I tend to agree with
him um is it
sustainable well it's it's certainly um
a fairly remote location it's in a
hamlet you a hamlet that has largely
linear
um development it is it is sort of in
Congress then to dump a housing estate
on top of that I don't I don't think
that is is
justifiable and whilst the benefits you
know some of the large buildings will be
removed many of the large buildings
would remain and hence would that change
the the landscape very much I wouldn't
have thought so but introducing a very
Urban designed um development would
certainly change the landscape so again
I I'm you know against that Council M
has already raised the the large number
of holding objections um drainage seems
to be an issue so that there is an awful
lot I think going against this
development and it is you know rather
concerning when you see um a planning
application come forward and then an
additional planning application and and
the changes seem to be um limited so no
I don't I don't see the merits in this
development and unless one of the
councilors brings up some points I've
missed I I will be um I think supporting
the officer's objections but I will um
listen to the rest of the debate with
interest thank you thank you councelor
Norris
please thank you m thank you Mr chairman
uh I agree with the uh comment about the
number of holding objections from
consult tees and I don't think this
application has a great deal going for
it actually it seems to be in an totally
unsustainable location requiring the use
of a car we've heard there's no foot
paath on the local roads the bus service
only comes on Thursday of each week um
there doesn't seem to be a proven need
for housing in this particular area as
such uh there's no affordable housing
proposed in the application there entire
loss of employment land that doesn't
seem to be an upto-date ecological
report there is a question about flood
risk um so I I really at the moment feel
very much inclined not to support the
application so at this point Thank you
thank you councel Stringer
please thank you chair uh yes I was part
of the decision making process in
February 2020 when we looked at this a
similar application to this one the
previous one uh uh within all of these
issues I always try and find where I can
agree with people uh and I agree with
the applicant agent on on on certainly
one issue and that's the one of
affordable housing if you don't have a
housing need survey in a very rural
location it it could be very socially
isolating and damaging to then put
affordable and social housing in that
location because you are basically
cutting people off without a support
network and that can be deeply damaging
socially uh economically uh as well and
actually that is the true definition of
unsustainable development so I agree
with one part with the agent that if
this were to go ahead we should seek a
commuted sum to deliver affordable
housing elsewhere in mids suffk or in
this area uh I have say after that
agreement I then fundamentally disagree
with with everything basically now about
this application I have to say I'm
totally disappointed that the comments
made at the previous refusal have just
been basically ignored we've got the
same application again and to keep doing
the same thing again and again and
expecting a different result is actually
the definition of Madness I was
expecting to see either some a smaller
number of possibly even bigger more
luxurious homes here very ecologically
big built and sustainably built
something that would lessen the number
lessen the impact but actually up the
profit for the developer I was expecting
that didn't get it I was perhaps
expecting live work units they're
becoming incredibly popular elsewhere
where our economic development team
could be supporting this where you've
got you know quite large luxury homes
with a business attached to them what
you know that's the sort of thing we
should be looking at in these unique
circumstances so I have to say chair
I'll be voting against this again is
with a very heavy heart because I think
there's a scheme here that could work
but frankly this one is still not
it thank you councelor War boys
please thank you chair I was listening
with interest to councelor stringer's
remarks um and that they it there some
positive proposals for this
site uh in particular the live work
units which I think would bridge the gap
between the loss of um
employment
space and um housing development in
another context I think i''d be
favorable towards developing a
Brownfield S as
housing however um you know as is
indicated by the fact we're looking for
commutated sums for affordable housing
this is an
unsustainable site it's excessive for
the settlement
36% increase there's no um there's no
apparent need for housing on that sort
of scale within a hamlet such as
Kenton uh and Council Mel has already
drawn attention to the the number of
holding objections from our
statutory consules um I'm particularly
concerned about the attenuation basing
being within u a flood zone it it seems
uh counterproductive to me me so I I
think I would support the C the officers
recommendations thank you thank you
thank you councelor uh we will move to
the second round of the debate unless
somebody would like to start with
proposal then let's move back into
debate councilor ghou
please uh nothing uh to add for me thank
you chair
yeah uh Council
melon um I don't think I have much to
add but I'm happy to um propose refusal
on the lines of the uh the officer's
recommendation Council Mel thank you we
do have a proposal I'm seeking a second
it
please chair I'm happy to Second The
Proposal councilor mayor thank you um
use the hands up facilities does anybody
else want to continue
debate
no okay I think we're pretty much there
we do have a propos it we do have a
second my own thoughts on this pretty
much um agree with all the previous
members um key bit being sustainability
land contamination the loss of
employment land the attenuation baites
and being within a flood zone and as
Council Stringer put it there is no
change from the previous one very very
little change um for all those reasons
I'll be voting against this um so
therefore we will move to the vote at
once uh the area planning manager
summarized The Proposal uh no need to
read out the recommendations there are
huge amounts of them we've all read them
fully thank you yes I must I do feel
like I'm not quite doing my job today
and I'm sort of faced with uh nine uh
reasons for refusal here uh so
essentially there was no change to the
recommendation that was discussed so
what is before members is as page uh 257
and 258 does it go further than that and
indeed
259 um and in summary um there are both
Technical and subjective uh reasons uh
for refusal contained within your papers
um so there are technical issues in
terms of uh the affordable housing and
lack of U ecology and and so on but also
ultimately uh we have um the subjective
reasons in terms of the definition of
harm to listed buildings and um the
principle of the development in in terms
of its sustainability credentials um I
will say no more I think we'll leave it
there um they are as your papers and
that is the thank you very much that's
the recommendation going forward thank
you uh therefore I'll ask the governance
officer to conduct the electronic vote
please thank you chair members could
please go to their modern. goov app and
go to today's agenda and click the plus
sign in the top right hand corner this
will bring out the subsection on voting
voting SL attendance if you click on
that it will take you to the vote which
is currently in progress and shown as a
light blue color it'll be about halfway
down the
page
should ready for one more vote
ch
sorry chair the app's gone wrong again
uh it does this every meeting I have to
say uh I'll be voting for the
recommendation chair thank you Robert
you happy with that recorded vote yep
that is absolutely fine chair so I can
confirm after taking counselor string
his vote verbally and also as per the
previous two items councelor gust will
not vote as the board member that it is
seven votes for which makes it unanimous
chair thank you that is carried um we're
now going to change the chair of the
meeting I'm going to hand back to uh
councelor Kathy Guthrie who will now
become the chair of the meeting coun
go well thank you very much councelor
humph um thank you for your chairing of
that and uh we move on if we may please
um have can I just confirm with Robert
that we have um counselor Carter and
counselor Mueller um ready and waiting
listening and any speakers for this next
applic
yes chair if I just run through I
believe I've contacted councelor Carter
who I believe is here if councelor
Carter if you are here could you just
please let us know um because I can't
get participants paying up at the
second I raised my hand I don't know if
oh brilliant sorry I didn't see that
though counselor but thank you um we've
got also um let me just check councelor
M I'm present thank you thank you thank
you very much councelor and we've got uh
Laura Dudley Smith as the applicant
sorry the agent and Alex zarowski as the
applicant so we are all here to commence
chair thank you very much indeed in that
case then can I ask Gemma to um present
the case please which is um full
planning application residential
development of 141 dwellings 49
affordable with Associated access
Landscaping imunity space and parking
thank you thank you chair I'll just
share my
screen hopefully that's come up
now so um thank you counc g that's as
you said um application here for 141
dwellings this is site 3C and 3D south
of gun Cotton white in stay Market uh
you may remember this came before you on
the third March and was deferred so I'll
run through some things briefly and pick
up on the reason for deferral but just
just to clarify so this is the
approximate location of the site just uh
in St Market close to the
A14 and zoing in slightly there we can
see we've got uh existing areas of
ceders Park to the north Tesco here and
if I go down one more slide you can just
see we've got the A14 to the north and
this is the
a120 so um two areas of the site um both
previously have got planning permission
that's extent so area 3C has got uh
out extent consent for 68 dwellings and
3D has got consent for the commercial
which is now outside of this application
site because that's been commenced and
indeed operating in several cases and
also has consent for 48 dwellings on so
that would be 116 so we're looking at an
additional 25 as part of this
application constraint wise we got a
foot path running through the site and
around but that's essentially the the
main points on that
one so as mentioned this was deferred
from committee previously with the
reason being to explore the potential
provision of a local equipped area for
play
um this area essentially through the
site is a
um biodiversity and suds area that had
been implemented following the partial
implementation of Area 3 D so that isn't
somewhere that we've been able to do
anything but we can just see in here
there was a further area of the suds
that was able to be used um for the
place base but still operate as the suds
uh I'll come to that a little bit more
detail in in a moment but just so
essentially to say that following that
deferral we have been able to include uh
a play area on the
site so just to run through this is the
existing consents so we've got the
commercial area uh to the far right hand
side the various uh consents uh
dwellings on site one site and the other
sorry it doesn't quite join up but
hopefully it gives you a flavor of what
was previously consented and as I said
is in fact extent on both
sides um just some previous issues that
we had also picked up before so just
wanted to run through them um hopefully
today to help answer those questions
from previously the site does include
some triple parking uh which is
obviously something we've not been keen
on and wanted to avoid in accordance
with the suff parking guidance but in
those cases where there is triple
parking it's in excess of Standards so
there are an additional space so it's
not considered unacceptable in that
regard the there I believe there's a
query previously about refuse uh and bin
storage so to confirm that we do have a
plan that shows adequate turning areas
and also presentation areas and
collection points that's been confirmed
with Waste Services who have confirmed
that that is
acceptable and then just to revisit the
site layout plan as I mentioned this is
the area in here that we were looking
out for the uh play area that was uh
required so to zoom in on that area what
we've got is um a bound pathway that
offers opport various opportunities for
scooter riding running that kind of
thing this small area then we've got the
equipped playist we've got natural
Boulders we've got a uh log
climbing area we've got a slide and then
is also a swing so that's what's been
proposed in there and then we've also
got this of loop around a um Wild Flower
Meadow in the area so includes a lot of
natural planting around as well and then
we've been provided with this by uh the
developers that gives you a probably
clearer idea than the plan does of what
we've got so you can see with the
entrance there the bound pathway the
various player equipments and just just
in front of us the sort of small
Wildflower Meadow area that would also
have a a loop of um moan grass to offer
access around there as
well just to pick up briefly on the
elevations I wasn't proposing to run
through all of the uh elevations for
members because they are quite extensive
but they are in your bundles and
obviously if there's anything specific
you wanted to to look at more than happy
to do so but just just briefly run
through so this is the elevation a on
the top of the row um showing that
essentially through the center of the
side looking across onto this area and
elevation B again through sort of
through the center of that
site
Street elevation C and D so now we're
through the center of this area of the
site and then again at the bottom
looking across that edge of the
site and finally this is the essentially
part of the frontage onto gun cotton
way just to again briefly run through
the photos appreciating that we did do
this previously but I'll I'll be brief
but uh if anybody wants anything further
feel free to ask so this is looking a
long gun cotton way uh and we can see
the existing commercial development to
our left and tesos would be to our right
and coming down again with the uh
commercial development on our left and
Tesco to our right com down again so
this is the roundabout part of the
entrance to the site and looking back up
gunon
way again from that roundabout looking
up towards ceders Park on our right and
on our left the development site this is
the existing entrance that's been
commenced on part of the
site and looking across
again the
site and again some further uh extant
Works having taken place this is the uh
foot path that runs through essentially
the center of the site and then looking
back up this is the area where as I
mentioned that wasn't possible to
include the play area because of that
existing Suds and biodiversity
area and again across the
site and looking up again through to
seedar and then commercial units uh at
the top of the photograph
and then just work at the top of the
site and then to again to go back to the
site layout so just to confirm there was
existing consent on the 3C for 68 units
and 3D for 48 units so the proposal is
an additional 25 this does take the
density to 40.3 dwellings per hectare
but this does comply with cs9 which
requires a density of at least 30
dwellings per hectare and at least 40
dwellings per hect in sustainable
locations in towns which would suggest
this being stay Market in the town in a
sustainable location would be acceptable
in that regard with for
cs9 to achieve the additional dwellings
The Proposal reduces the number of
larger properties compared to the extand
consents and proposes more smaller
properties so to confirm this is an
additional four one bedrooms an
additional 13 two bedrooms and that
includes two Bungalows and an additional
18 three beds whilst we're reducing the
number of four beds by
10 the um sorry so as per the deferral
the plans have been amended to include a
play area it couldn't be in the Central
Area due to the studs and existing
ecological Corridor for
biodiversity however on discussion with
SEC floods the area to the South and
here could be used without affecting the
sud scheme and I can confirm that still
provides a scheme in accordance with
such requirements and has been agreed by
SEC floods public realm War included in
the design of the proposal and have no
objection overall the consider proposal
is considered to be acceptable in
principle following on from the exent
consents it is for an additional 25
units and it does increase the density
but also the number of smaller units the
density is acceptable with regards to
cs9 and the proposal has been amended to
provide an equipped area for players
requested and a condition is proposed to
secure the implementation of that uh
overall The Proposal is considered to be
acceptable with regards the additional
units and density and not to result in
harm such that subject to 106 and
conditions as set out on page 41 and 42
the recommendation is for approval thank
you
chair thank you for that um hands up
facility um do any members have any
questions for the planning
officer no I can't see that we
do right then we'll move on uh we don't
have a representative from the town
Council and objector or supporter so
I'll now ask the agent and the applicant
to speak and we have Laura Dudley Smith
and Alex zorski for three minutes to be
shared thank
you good morning I just confirm so Alex
Sosi um representative of bway homes um
will be available to answer the
questions any any questions at the end
um but SS of the three minutes I'll I'll
be dealing with that myself thank
you good morning members oh good
afternoon members um thank you for
allowing us to participate in today's
meeting my name is Laura Dudley Smith
and I'm speaking this morning this
afternoon from St and Parker planning
Consultants acting on behalf of bway
homes as you recall this application was
recently considered by yourselves at
your last committee meeting on the 3rd
of March a determination on the
application was deferred however for the
consideration of whether whether there
was an opportunity to provide a play
area on the site bway homes have taken
these comments on board and reviewed
options carefully with the project team
as a result a space has been identified
on parcel 3C on the southern boundary of
the site through some redesigning of
this area the space has been made large
enough to accommodate a toddler and
young children's play area which will be
suitable for this location amids
residential development its relationship
with the proposed new homes is in
accordance with national guidelines for
features of this scale and nature the
the specific equipment has been selected
following liaison with babber mids
council's public realm team suff County
STS and the planning officer the
intention has been to provide a play
area that has a natural visual
appearance but which also offers
equipment that will be well used and
thus provide a worthwhile feature to
supplement the larger scale offerings
already available nearby a swing and a
slide are therefore provide provided
along with some more organic features
such as play bolders and balancing logs
to encourage informal play and enjoyment
also as a studs feature the space
previously served two purposes one was
to accommodate filter drains and the
other was as a bioet bio retention
feature the fter drains have been
re-rooted slightly to ensure that they
can still run under this area and the
bio retention feature was excess to
requirements previously simply making
use of this space above the drains to
enhance the sustainable drainage system
as such suffet County Council s's team
POS no objection to the use of the space
as a play area instead the area will
include a picnic bench and grass amenity
space and shall be enclosed with hedging
and railings to ensure the safety of the
young children using it a number of
parking spaces have also been relocated
to minimize car movements within the med
within the immediate vicinity as
previously discussed we hope that this
new application with development
previously approved on Parcels 3 C and
3D will allow for the delivery of a
scheme which better suits local housing
demand and current market conditions in
turn this will also offer an increased
provision of affordable homes section
106 contributions and SE funds we trust
that the inclusion of this play era
which ex sees local policy requirements
in the interests of satisfying specific
local circumstances and Associated
concerns will therefore now allow you to
support this application in line with
your officer's recommendation thank you
for your time myself and bway homes are
happy to answer any questions you may
have thank you very much indeed um hands
up facility do any members have any
questions
please I can't see any so thank you very
much indeed we now move on to the ward
members and um uh councelor Carter would
you like to go
first thank you it means I can't a copy
off my colleague this time around
doesn't it well it gives you the
opportunity to get the glory doesn't it
certainly oh I'm quite resigned to the
fact that this is going to go go ahead
after the last meeting and I have to
admit I do quite like this application I
like the um I like the reduction of
houses I like the having fewer uh but
more one bedroom and two-bedroom
properties and a few larger ones I do
quite love the play area which is quite
it's it's a nice play area it's a shame
we can't do the whole development as one
big play area and reduce properties down
to one which much appreciate but I can
see it's not going to happen um but
other than that it's it's a it been well
worked out the applicant has been very
um agreeable and very um very helpful
with uh making the
changes um I'd love to say we've made
progress with the crossing which my
colleague may have done but I've heard
nothing back from uh our County
counselor um other than that yeah it's
uh it's a reason to be sustainable
location despite the lack of links it's
a it's a good development regards with
housing it' be lovely if they were all
sustainably built well they are but more
so um it'd be lovely if that that was
that but it's not going to happen so
yeah I've
got um no further objections than what I
raised last time which basically we
realize what the fal was for so um thank
you I will let uh my colleague hopefully
make more sense than I've just
made um would you like questions now or
wait until councelor Müller has
spoken um I'll wait until Council Müller
has spoken thank you very much in that
case just keep your cam well Council
Müller would you like to make your
statement and then we can ask members
for questions if at all thank you thank
you very much chair yes first of all I
would like to thank bway Holmes for the
excellent play area they no recommending
for this particular site I think it's
one of the best I've actually seen um
for a small play era on the whole of
Cedar Parker state so so well done for
that um following the previous meeting I
did get in contact with County counselor
my main concern with traffic was really
associated with site 3D and the little
roundabout that particular area is
incredibly busy and a child was knocked
down 18 months ago outside McDonald's on
on the main road there um but highways
who inform the county count that they
are satisfied that road is safe um so
not being an expert on highways myself
um I would have to go along with their
recommendations I totally agree with
what councilor Carter has said I welcome
the smaller size homes I think we need
more starter homes um the site has got a
cycle stroke footpath right around it
and cedus park as many members would
know is has got extremely good cycle and
foot path throughout the estate
therefore I am more than happy to uh
would recommend that members approve
this application thank you
chair thank you councelor Müller just as
a point um I think we debated it the
last time unfortunately I'm I'm grateful
for both counselors to approach um
highways but probably when further
developments come perhaps on the other
side of the road there might be more
funding available to look for um
Crossing Arrangements but at the moment
if it's deemed safe unfortunately who
are we to argue and of course that comes
outside this planning application so can
I ask if members have any questions for
our Ward members please if you'd like to
use the hands up
facility
no can't see any thank you very much
gentlemen thank you
so we now I will try to turn my camera
off but my finger stuck I'm sorry about
this sorry thank you um so we will now
move on to debate um if we can um in the
first instance um go around in
alphabetical order and I'll start with
counselor G would you like to make a
comment
please thank you very much uh mad Madam
chair um i' I'd like this uh application
when we when we considered it pre ly
particularly uh with regard to uh the
provision of uh more smaller starter
homes these are much needed and um I was
very pleased to to to see them I think
the scheme is is is a very good one and
I'm delighted about the very positive
response in terms of the provision of a
play area which uh as it's just been
said uh looks very very attractive by
having lived a sheltered life I hadn't
come across the concept of a play
boulder before and I was wondering what
that was like but having seen the photo
I wouldn't mind to go myself there I
think this is uh this is a very welcome
response to our request uh for
consideration of play area uh and um I I
would be happy to support um the
approval thank you thank you councelor
gold I think there's an age restriction
on the play area um
can we now move on to councelor humph
please mam
chair hopefully I'm on yes thank you um
I was happy in principle with the last
time this came towards us um and I'm now
really pleased that the developer and
the offices have managed to come up with
compromise that provides that play area
which was the sticking point last time
for I remember so it's great it's a
sustainable area it's been a long time
coming we wanted this area developing in
stone market for quite some time now
it's sustainable in the fact that you
can walk or cycle into town you're close
to a large supermarket and EES local
businesses on the two industrial Estates
that very close to it and of course with
the Gateway 14 that's emerging and of
course you've got good access to the A14
which is just literally around the
corner um I've got no issues with this
whatsoever and it will get my support
thank
you thank you
councelor and now we come to councelor
please yeah thank you chair um yes
there's some uh positive things here
from the last um scheme that we looked
at I like the play area um not so keen
on the triple parking and I think the
density is um also problematic to a
certain extent this site has good
connectivity in some ways you know the
cycopath foot paath um in other ways
it's not so great you've got a cross gun
cotton way to to access T Test goes and
um you know I I hope that some sort of
Crossing will eventually be provided um
you know perhaps if the um the county
councilor for that area was was engaged
um at some point in the future it will
happen um my main concern really is
about is about traffic um and and having
been up this area um when the cues form
for uh for Costa and McDonald's I mean
it does it does get pretty horrendous
there and I'm sure this new development
will will only exacerbate the problems
um but I don't see a kind of policy
reason to to sort of stand against this
but I have my concerns and I'll listen
to the debate as it goes on thank you
thank you councelor melan um Jemma can
we just um clarify the triple parking I
thought we'd done away with
that sorry just having trouble unmuting
uh so the there the only triple parking
is where the third space is in excess of
Standards so we could cut that extra
space off and they would still be in
compliance so the having it as extra
over and above their standard is is why
that that's considered
acceptable okay I'll let members
consider that then thank you thank you
and it was on the last one anyway wasn't
it and so we didn't use it as a yes
there hasn't been any change to that no
no right okay I'm just trying to clarify
cuz I was aware it came up last time
yeah I thought it did yeah thank you um
councilor mayor your comments
please thanks chair um I wasn't part of
the uh committee that heard this the
first time around so I've come to this
aresh and I think it looks a a
reasonable development um the play area
is obviously a very positive addition um
the reduction in in um the four bedroom
houses I think he positive um
one perhaps uh plea we we have
electrical charging points but only if
you have a parking space on your plot
well people living in the the the
apartment blocks will no doubt one day
want an electric car what do they do um
so one day we'll get a an application
that comes in that provides access to
that sort of facility to all residents
but that's really nitpicking so I think
it's a positive um a positive
application and I will be supporting
thank
you thank you councelor um councelor
Norris please thank
you thank you madam chairman uh I'm very
pleased actually that the uh developers
have been agreeable to including apply
area which I thought was essential um I
still have slight reservations about the
traffic issues and a potential Crossing
or otherwise but apart from from that um
as I say I'm very pleased that we have
some Community facilities namely the
play area and I will be supporting this
application thank you thank you for that
councelor Norris councelor
Stringer thank you chair uh yes I was
part of the original uh deferral uh and
actually uh good job we did uh because
for me um the play area here is not a
positive addition it's absolutely
essential uh to make this anywhere near
sustainable uh I still have some
reservations about the design somewhat
uh but it's it's bog standard for what
we do these days uh it could be more
sustainable in its construction uh but I
don't think I could refuse on that basis
I do still have reservations about this
uh its connectivity in terms of walking
and cycling to cross that road uh and
this is where i' just like to take
slight issue uh with with our Council uh
and uh the chair used the phrase well
who are we to uh you know uh go against
the the recommendation of the highways
officer uh well actually that's our role
to double check this to make sure this
is indeed sustainable development and
this is where I think we actually uh
should be inviting the county counselor
along to our meetings to double check
that the work of those offices uh if
there is any future plans to make these
happen so that we get a more rounded
view in these having said that I will be
supporting the application very much on
balance and and I uh also uh
congratulate the developer on actually
listening to what we've said Thank You
chair thank you for that councelor
Stringer councelor War
boys yes thank you thank you chair I
think I could just um really so go from
comments previously I I it is good to
see efficient use of land you know
housing density is just over 40 houses
per Hector but this is
uh uh in lots of ways to sustainable
location close to town uh
the types of housing is is is is good
the increasing numbers are affordable
and smaller
houses um and it is supported by our
statutory
consules I do think that you know that
the the deferral and which has brought
about this the inclusion of a player is
is is a is a good step forward I think
it's it will um perhaps cut down on sort
of uh pressure to cross the bu that very
busy road and again I think there is a
but there is still a need for a
pedestrian Crosser some form there and
possibly some form of traffic
controls um in the
conditions attached to this I I I would
like to see a sort of um inclusion of
some sustainable and energy strategy
including the the retrofit cost for
properties on the development uh from
the last meeting it was apparent that
the the gas main is there and gas
central heating is the default position
um
but uh this is very soon this this will
not be sort of
possible and so I can't really support
it from that point of
view
um so but overall this this is an
improvement on the
previous application thank you uh thank
you councelor War booys you're
suggesting conditions are you suggesting
the recommendation for approval
then I I I think um conditions for
improval yes i' certainly like to see a
sustainability no are you recommending
approval and if so you wanted that added
as a condition and that's where I was
coming from it was that you yes that
that's exactly what I'd like to see yes
thank you so are you recommending
approval yes I I recommend approval with
that that condition yes can we ask the
officers before I go for a second or
whether that can be
added I'm sorry CH I'm I'm a little
unclear as to the nature of the
condition in the recommendation we have
a water energy and resource efficiency
measures as the sustainability officer
in environmental health as recommends in
our papers on page
41 what are we adding to that I'm a
little
unclear I I think it's the retrofitting
costs with regards to achieving Zero
Energy net uh zero Net Zero carbon
emissions particularly as that there's
going it it will be dependent on gas
heating right okay there two aspects to
this um first of all we're dealing with
financial um contribution of some kind
which I would probably put more in
towards a 106 bracket rather than a
condition equally though for both the
106 and condition that is an unknown
amount um I don't know it would be
reasonable it would wouldn't comply with
the test of reasonable testical
conditions um as necessary potentially
but also how is that reasonable when we
don't know what that sums might be it
would be an unnecessary burden in placed
on the developer at this current stage
and I don't think I have the policy
position to back that up thank you for
that John in which case um councelor War
Boyce do you want to withdraw your
proposal
um or are you happy to still continue
without that I think I'm happy to
consider the proposal to accept right
that's very kind of you thank you very
much indeed in which which case do I
have a seconder to that
please yes councelor
Norris thank you madam chairman yes I'm
very pleased to second that proposal for
approval thank you thank you very much
now would anybody like to speak to the
motion
please I can't see any further hands up
in which case then um can we ju just be
clear um again it's it's a
long discussion here or page 41 has
quite a lot on there John do you want to
just sort of briefly go to that no it it
isn't um we're going um to the
recommendation as laid out in the
papers
withdrew withdrew his uh additional
condition after hearing your explanation
thank you I was just a little unclear
unfortunately my teams is acting up and
I've just realized
um others has cut out a little bit as
well for other people so concerns me
that you lost anybody has has everybody
been I think we've just lost the case
officer potentially is Gemma still there
I'm I am back now it completely crashed
asked his question I think so I I missed
that but hopefully no problem in my
absence yeah so I was just conscious
that that I do hope that is not a
degrading issue for all of us anyway
we'll we'll carry on um the uh so the
recommendation is on page 41 uh um of of
your report 41 and 42 um obviously this
includes the provision of a section 106
agreement obligation for affordable
housing early years Primary School
transport contribution uh management of
the public open space the and that would
include the the extra space we now have
put forward travel plan contributions uh
mitigation for reptiles and uh the
Implement uh the removal of the
implementation of the extent consents
that have been approved previously
because they would still be in their
implementation time period they need to
be removed so we have that as the 106
that is on top of obviously this is also
a sill uh uh Community infrastructure
Levy site so those uh Provisions would
also be coming forward and then we have
the uh conditions uh as per your papers
I'm not going to go through each one of
those but they are unchanged and and as
as stated on in your papers um and
therefore the recommendation going
forward is one of
approval sot put that in our um
electronic voting I'd be most grateful
thank you thank you chair that is all
ready to go so if members could please
go to the modern. goov app and go to
today's agenda in the top right hand
corner the plus sign will open the
subsection of voting SL attendance if
you click on that and go to the voting
tab the vote will show us it show in
progress in a light blue
color
all
thank you chair all votes have now been
received so that is seven votes for and
one against so the motion is carried
thank you very much indeed now if
everybody's happy to keep going do you
just want five minutes break and then
we'll reconvene and can someone advise
um councelor uton and the speakers for
the next case if everyone's happy with
that agreed chair lovely just five
minutes then if we may
please thank
you
good afternoon everyone watching just to
give an update this is Robert car with
the governance officer we are just
missing one of the parish council
representatives to speak this afternoon
and we're trying to get hold of them so
the committee will restart at 1:00
whilst we try and get in touch with the
representative thank
you
well good afternoon everybody and
welcome back to our reconvened
development B committee uh we had um
taken an early lunch break hoping for a
member of the parish council for the
last application to be able to join us
but unfortunately despite everybody's
best efforts we haven't been able to
raise him um and councelor Aon um is of
course here as board
member so um without further Ado can we
start the presentation which is uh for
the erection of three numbered detached
dwellings and Associated parking
Landscaping utilizing the public has
access at rattl so John if you'd like to
present the case please thank you very
much hello sorry I've just been
disappeared for about 3 minutes because
I've had to reset my whole computer can
you just give me one minute this I don't
know what's going on I just had to reset
the whole thing two seconds I've just
got to pull all the PowerPoint back up
again and everything that I had open oh
two seconds two seconds right that's
that back
and it might be the case that we've got
to relog in again for the modern. goov
when it comes to a voting system as well
it might have timed us out I've um
unfortunately I've just had some update
Wednesday morning is the update for the
county and it just forced a
reset oh right everything I had set up
is just gone bear with me I'll be there
two
seconds
um right
okay thank you for everyone's
forbearance yes my
apologies right let's put that back in
there
Perfect come down I don't know who that
is who is the hand
up Andrew it's
you
that's councelor melon you mean yeah
yeah yeah yes councelor melon indeed
indeed oh apologies I didn't I didn't
realize that was still up that's right
notice the 90% of the time and then when
they're not required I find them yeah
chairman I really my humble apologies
for the it uh go now yes Absol apologies
for that can you all see the PowerPoint
I'm hoping that's working yep great
thank you so this is felim uh six uh
land to the rear of six bells in felsham
uh it's a planning application for free
uh detached dwellings Associated parking
and uh utilizing the existing Public
House access uh this is to show you
where felim is um and the site is
essentially within the main bulk of the
village going a little bit closer uh six
bells is the grade two uh listed
property and it's fairly Central to the
Village um and we have a large amenity
area Village Green uh to the left and we
have more historical properties that
surround that that area we have U to the
north uh primarily uh more recent post B
Bungalows we have a more modern housing
estate mostly two-story uh development
uh to the right um this is mainly part
of the conservation area along with all
of this uh this particular element over
here is outside the conservation area
but beyond that is also then back in the
conservation area you'll see that in a
moment if I go to the next uh uh slide
so in terms of constraints the list of
buildings uh so there's clearly the site
in terms of the orange um hashed uh lay
layout there um the list of buildings
are those in orange and red um so in
this case we have uh gray two orange uh
listed buildings uh that's not to say
there's a lot of historical uh buildings
in this area these are fairly historic
uh buildings along along the edge here
and we also have uh in red the gray two
Star Church uh to the South uh this is
all within the settlement boundary of
the village which is this brown line
here and it's uh the site and immediate
surroundings are within the conservation
area as well but there's no specific uh
designation for the site beyond the
conservation area and being within the
settlement boundary um it is within the
curtilage of the listed building as the
[Music]
pub so the redline plan uh this is the
defined site it includes part of the
public house uh car part for technical
reasons which I'll come to
later and this is the proposed layout
but before we go into detail with this I
think we need to sort of step back and
come back to that in a moment and what
we're going to do is start with this
layout plan this is uh an appeal
decision uh layout plan
uh so an application was refused uh in
2011 for two dwellings uh as shown on
this plan uh within the bear um Car rear
uh Garden area of the the public house
uh this went to appeal and it was
dismissed it was refused on two reasons
the first reason was essentially there
is a historical wall that goes down I
presuming you can all see my cursor um
the wall goes down along the edge of the
site and this driveway to get to to the
two houses would effectively break
through that historical wall the other
reason for uh the uh refusal was that
the access was deemed to be poor in
terms of visibility and uh not least
because of the way the junction works
here um in terms of the appeal only one
of those reasons was upheld um
essentially the brick uh the retention
of the uh historical wall the inspector
did not uphold the access uh issu and
visibility
issues so essentially we have an appeal
decision that is a material
consideration that establishes as well
as the settlement boundary as well the
principle of residential development uh
within the garden of this listed
building of course from that decision
there has been a number of refusals um
and primarily they have been centered
around trying to find an access route
through this wall and trying to justify
whether or not this is actually a
historical wall or not this application
this time has come from an alternative
position this position is that the wall
remains uh untouched this time and we
share the access with the public
house um now this to allow to happen
will essentially take away two parking
spaces at this point uh in terms of the
Practical uh nature of it as you come in
already to get to the rear car park of
the public house this is not as shown on
site we'll see the photos in the moment
what's on site at the moment is just
actually a graveled area um so
theoretically it's not marked out um but
to demonstrate what could be achieved in
parking terms uh we have a marked out
plan here and this plan shows an
expansion of the parking area to
accommodate four parking spaces rather
than the two that are replaced but from
the mitigation of the burden of devel
velopment we only need to secure the
further two dwellings H sorry two uh
parking spaces uh and that is in your
recommendation that is also why we have
the extended Redline plan to enable no
real change to the parking area apart
from the additional two spaces
required in terms of
access um so the idea would be that we
use the existing access to the public
house
now the proposal did up till very
recently include markings along the
public Highway and these are the dash
lines on the plan before you and of
course we've spent quite a lot of time
in the office of report trying to
demonstrate these markings within the
photographs that are included in the
officer report um to to sort of
demonstrate the effect of these however
there has been significant um
representation on the markings proposed
uh that includes a bfic a petition that
was mentioned earlier of 183
signatures and while I think there's
been a degree of confusion on the point
of markings um the point on the impact
of the markings within the conservation
area uh visually uh is understood but
skipping past that essentially what we
now have is those markings removed from
the scheme the highways Authority have
confirmed that they are not actually
needed and so they do not now form part
of The Proposal or your recommendation
and their impact on the character of the
conservation area is therefore
removed so then we have the three plots
proposed so plot one uh plot one is
around uh is the first one you come to
is you're coming up that driveway into
the site uh it's around 7.9 m to the
ridge um with a range of EES Heights
around 2 to uh 5 m High uh um it's also
the plot one is the only objection from
your heritage team in terms of the barn
style appearance given the weather
boarding uh that is proposed the
dwelling does use weather uh sorry
weatherboarded Timber to promote a more
rural appearance but it could be changed
uh to Brick or render um the design
approach though is felt to have two main
advantages over a traditional looking
dwelling in this location firstly the
overlooking from any first floor window
and if I move
on um the any any rear windows that
would Overlook existing um properties
are essentially removed uh we have uh
roof light Windows um but nothing that
would cause direct overlooking uh from
an amenity point of view it also allows
um the building to then have more
windows on the side elevation as you're
coming into the S um which I think is
more attractive uh welcome as you come
to the side the timber itself being
black there are Glimpse views through
existing properties within the Village
Green and surroundings and you will see
this building at a distance and but
seeing this building at a distance with
weather boarding that's black is
considered to be less
intrusive um in material terms and
coloring uh than perhaps a more domestic
looking uh
property um we then move on to plot two
this property again
relatively low for Modern Property at
7.6 m to the ridge um it has more
traditional uh elements to it and it's
certainly picked up on the design of the
local Flint in the area and that's found
on a number of buildings along the green
uh but also the pub
itself this is Central to the uh sort of
Courtyard that's being created and then
finally we have plot three again 7.4 to
the ridge about 5 m to the Eevees height
uh this is Georgian Edwardian style
property um and mindful again of
potential of overlooking it takes the
historic idea of recess blocked up
Windows as a feature so you don't have
the mass that's dominant is broken up
but you don't actually have the window
that overlooks we do have a tall uh
Landing window for the hallway that is
proposed to be obscurely glazed as it's
not necessary to be looking out of that
um but otherwise it's overlooking is is
um is dealt with
accordingly now I'm skip past the
pictures there I've actually got a
number of photographs obviously this the
pub that's the public house with vendor
and the Flint detailing uh that's a very
dominant and uh intriguing feature as
you come around that corner and really
attractive actually I do like it and we
have the entrance the existing entrance
to the public house
there and I've got up various pictures
just to show the Corner sorry the corner
as you come around and we just going to
go inside and we have the current
graveled car park at the
moment and just looking
around that car park and as we come back
around the pub what I'm going to do is
I'm going to skip to Google Street View
in a minute because I think it's easier
to put into context how you travel
around uh this site so uh this is again
it's the Village Green at this point um
to the uh West of the
site and I'm just looking back at the
corner as you go around to where you go
into the pub now I'll come back to this
so I'm going to this is probably a
dangerous thing to do but I'm going to
skip past my PowerPoint and very quickly
unshare and hopefully then share
again our Google street view um which is
obviously mindful that it's a couple of
years out of date because uh I don't
know when the last time van went around
to take pictures so if you bear with me
one moment
I'm hoping you can all now see a Google
Street View image chairman if you may
just confirm you can see that yes I can
yeah thank you so I'm at the point where
you have the village hall and as we
travel we got the church which is on the
south side of the public house and
hopefully I'm traveling and I'll try not
to do too fast so we travel in
slowly we have the church we also have a
village shop as well just there and as
we come
across we come up to the church and we
have the six bells public house on the
right hand
side I'm hoping is it loads up
reasonably well so that's the
entrance and in terms of uh the
questions around the E formity of the
the driveway as you can see at this
point the the the road are the road has
essentially a natural layby that has
been created over time out the
front compared to sort of the the
different whips further along and if we
just carry on and travel a little bit
further around you can see the corner as
we then approach The Village
Green and if I just get to that point
you can see some of the historical
buildings around the Village Green
itself and if I just quickly go back
around we can see the way around the
corner and the church on the right can
you go this way now and go back towards
the pub please I can carry on yes um so
I'm conscious that it there's a delay in
loading so I'm not trying to go too fast
hopefully as we travel back
around and we can see let that load
up the context of this direction which
would have been on the photos as
well thank you okay and I'll leave it
there and I'll switch back to the
presentation if that's
okay okay um lost that bit hang on B
there you go
right so uh the proposal has needed um
to consider a significant planning and
appeal history um it also has a number
of considerations in terms of the
location for residential amenity an
attractive uh historical
location um The Proposal though that has
resulted from all of that is considered
to be a very high quality scheme for
free popoke dwellings uh that have taken
architectural cues from the local area
and not just parachuted in these create
an attractive shared Courtyard and space
and share the existing unlimited access
to the public house without in our
opinion opinion uh being detrimental to
that the recommendation therefore in
conclusion is for one of approval thank
you thank you John um do members um want
to put their hands up for questions to
the officer
please councelor
Stringer thank thank you chair uh just
looking at the plan of of of how these
dwellings
are pushed into this can you show me
what the route is for the cars to access
the one at the back how they access
parking and stuff and how many can do
that thank you so this is um actually
sort of effectively a way round uh a
central feature so you can get through
and through to the back parking space
there and we have two uh parking spaces
within the garage at that point so that
is the route through and you can take it
either way CU that's a shared sort of
open shared Courtyard area with the
exception of the feature in the
middle um might help actually if I go
back up to the um illustration that
might possibly help I'll just quickly do
that does that show the arrangement
better so you can go between if I can if
I may on this uh yeah what is the
distance between now now you've got this
picture cuz these pictures are devilish
there's there's a gap between the house
on the right and house in the
middle that Gap to me looks
like at least half the length of a
car but it doesn't look like half the
length of a car on the plan no the the
these are obviously These are 3D and and
um they're not intended to be scaled off
but if I go back to the hopefully go
back to the layout um you can see that
Gap is actually an illusion of the the
picture uh there wouldn't be a gap there
to get through on the right hand side
the Gap is actually on the left hand
side um 3 m or so across in order to get
through I can I can get a specific
measurement if you need it but I'd have
to go and come back to you on that
because I can't do that and present at
the same time well that's my point the
3D maps are contrived they don't they're
not real um uh and and they may give a
false impression and I still um um care
careful Council
string I have Cy that you've
demonstrated me how a car can get in and
out of that parking
space um well I say that's debate so
shall we debate that and call him back
again councelor Stringer if we if we can
um yeah just happy to let that sit there
was a question with with the spaces he's
going to calculate for us yeah um who
else had their hands up to ask a
question of the officer please I'm sure
I saw someone
else
no okay then so we don't have any
further questions for the officer um I
do have one question actually um clearly
they've changed the route from the
driveway um just to refresh my memory
the previous one was two dwellings only
and now they've put three in just is
that confirmed yes the previous
application soorry the appeal
application was for two uhli two
dwellings um slightly different
configuration but uh and then this is
for fre
yes okay thank you um so we now move
on we haven't got the Paris Council but
councilor Aon did you get um any
paperwork to read
out not
chairman I'm sorry about that well we've
tried very hard and I'm sure I'm sure
the parish would have um liked to have
seen their representation but obviously
um difficulties happen during these
difficult times and obviously it's quite
a serious thing that they had to attend
to um so do we now have an objector Mr
Nicholas Pai um you have three minutes
to address the committee if you would
please thank you very
much hello I'm just unmuting
myself can everybody hear
me yes yes I can go for it
right oh
just I've gone down
now oh my computer's just switched off
bear with me do you do you want to um
just turn your video off and your voice
might come through a bit easier for you
for your um internet connections might
that help
you I'll just
try we can still hear you so that sounds
quite
good yeah unfortunately the presentation
I've got is on a separate computer which
is just decided to die on me well we
don't actually allow presentations as
such in the visual Oh you mean your your
written one that you need to speak on I
do beg your pardon
yes I
see
must be the atmospherics today causing
complete chaos with um internet
connections right right just rebooting
now I'm sorry no that's all right it's
just one of those things isn't it and um
unfortunately I live in the village
which has got a very poor internet
connection so everything is um liable to
go down at any time
well I'm sure if you have a word with
your county counselor she'll get on to
that I think it's in the process of
getting the
Broadband very difficult very
difficult um chair's councelor melon
here sorry to interrupt I'm I'm about to
lose power um UK power networks are here
they just going to turn it off briefly
could I request a five minute
recess um well appreciated on my behalf
well we seem to be doing that all time
um uh councelor melon yes we'll go for
it but it will be five minutes only
because there has been so many um uh uh
shortages today yeah sorry sorry
apologies but
um Robert do you want to just suspend
the meeting for five minutes and we'll
start again in five minutes and no
longer thank
you
apologies for that delay but we're all
back again and um so we can reconvene we
almost forgotten where we
are oh yes if you would then Mr P thank
you very much I'll try and keep the uh
video not working so that the uh Speech
could be heard better excellent thank
you the national planning policy
framework and development plan policy
seek to ensure that new developments
make a positive contribution to the
local character along with sustaining
and enhancing the significance of nearby
Heritage assets and this is not achieved
by this proposal as the infield
dwellings are within the immediate
setting of the listed six spells Pub and
The Wider setting of the church and
nearby listed properties and do not
achieve any enhancement of the setting
or make a positive contribution to the
fum Conservation Area and as such is
contrary to T10 gp1 sb2 h13 h15 h16 hb1
hb2 hb8 and hb9 of the mids local plan
policy C5 of the mids cor Strate
policies fc1 and fc. 1.1 of the mids
Focus review and the national planning
policy framework and should therefore be
refused with regards to the road
safety there was a meeting on the 18th
of March organized and chaired by Joe
Churchill MP with Mr mea from highways
Mr pman G from planning councelor and
myself to discuss the increased risk of
collision by using the Pub's access as a
route to the development and the
proposal to narrow the road by placing
Road markings in front of the pub and
the pub
opposite in order to improve visibility
spays during the meeting Joe church will
ask Mr mtia if the pro if the proposed
Road markings were not there would
highways allow the access to be used for
the development to to which Mr mateer
answered no we would not however within
15 minutes of the meeting Mr mateer had
agreed that the road markings were no
longer required and that visible spays
could be met without them and an email
was sent to planning as such on all
previous comments submitted by highways
and email sent in representation to the
petition regarding the road safety
highways have constantly stated that the
pub accesses substan Ed for the
intensification of use from the
development and is set back from the
road with poor visibility plac which do
not meet minimum requirements why
suddenly has this
changed and as the street view that Mr
pman was showing us as you come down
from the upper green the entrance to the
pub is so far back that you cannot even
see
it thank
you thank you for that do members have
questions uh for Mr penai
please I can't uh yes councilor melon um
mayor sorry councelor mayor sorry I
couldn't see who it was councelor mayor
thanks thanks chair um have there been
any accidents um with vehicles leaving
the pub in recent
years not to my knowledge no there's
been plenty of near misses no I
personally have had an accident just
along there but that was more than five
years ago with an ongoing car coming
straight at
me but you weren't coming out of the pub
at the time no I was traveling just in
front of the pub where cars are normally
parked thanks very much thank you any
further
questions I can't see any thank you very
much
indeed so we don't have a supporter um
and I'll now have the applicant to speak
Jeremy Heel you have three minutes if
you would please thank you very
much thank you chair um good afternoon
councils and thank you for allowing me
to um speak to you today um I'm
representing the applicants cordage
group who are a family-owned and
operated real estate
company um as your planning office
officer has summarized the property has
a planning history which establishes
clearly that the development of the site
for residential purposes is acceptable
as a matter of principle and indeed the
officer concludes that proposals
represent a very high quality scheme for
three bespoke dwellings something we
fully concur
with we know that the property is
located in the curage of a great listed
building and within felm Conservation
area which has guided the design process
and resulted in three extremely high
quality Residential Properties in our
opinion located some distance from the
public house to minimize any impact on
it the council's planning officer and
considering the impact of the proposals
on Heritage assets is happy that the
public benefits of the scheme outweigh
any perceived harm on Heritage
assets the proposals are of an extremely
high quality and we believe contribute
to the creation of a sense of
place the proposals will also have a
material benefit to the longer term
viability of public house by virtue of
the capital receipt for the sale of the
development site being invested back
Public
House is now exiting I'd like to touch
briefly on the question of the white
lining as it it's obviously been raised
a number of times uh the white lining
was intended as an enhancement of the
existing access Arrangements um but as
we understand the existing position is
that it is a safe access through length
of safe usage and through the speeds of
traffic through the Village um and on
that basis um and in conjunction with
our own Highway
engineer uh I'm happy to confirm that my
clients are willing to emit the white
lining if that is the will of planning
committee and that is how you'd like to
see the scheme developed so I'm very
happy to confirm that point and just
very briefly in response to council
stringers point we have tracked every
parking space in the scheme both for the
pub and the proposed houses and is
possible quite easy to drive a car in
and out of all the
spaces so to conclude uh the applicant
is content that the proposals are fully
compliant with the relevant local and
National planning policies and Achieve
sustainable devel development in line
with the
mppf we therefore trust that councils
will follow the advice of its experts
and Grant planning permission this
afternoon um I'd be happy to answer any
of your questions but otherwise thank
you very much for your
time um we have questions going up I
think I see councelor Stringer first and
then if Robert you can help me if I can
only see Council string at the moment
thank you chair uh yeah just to uh
reiterate about the parking so the more
modern Barn like dwelling if I'm parked
there's two car parking spaces Side by
sides there are two cars parked there if
I'm jumped into the car that's nearest
the house what is my route out of the
development are we able to bring the
plans up on
screen I will try one moment thank you
J
um so we talking about so you got if I I
just quickly the the gap between these
two by the way is a lot more than I
thought it was so it's 4.5 M just to
confirm that cuz I've just measured it
off the plan um in terms of plot one
these are the two space car garage space
garages and parking spaces so you would
effectively reverse and then go out that
way yeah I have nothing to add to that
that's that's very helpful John thank so
so so okay the other end how would you
then get into
it I would imagine you'd come in go
around and then go back in that way okay
thank
you although that that said I would
imagine that's possible to do that as
well possible John I believe that is
[Music]
possible um I wouldn't usually just just
as some members may have been aware the
councelor melon I believe list his phone
call but I believe he's back again can
we just confirm that counc melon is back
and did not miss
anything sorry I am back and I didn't
miss anything I switched my phone off
once I was back in on uh on teams
brilliant thank you very much councel I
just just wanted to confirm that for the
record thank
you thank you um so um who would also
like to have a question please I saw
several hands up and now they seem to
have gone again are there any further
questions no I just have a question um
although the the um entrance has altered
uh can can you advise
why it's gone to three dwellings as
opposed to the original
two um we simply took a view that um in
design terms um and in spatial terms it
was a large site um and easily able to
accommodate three dwellings I mean the
fact that it had two applied for you
know 10 years ago was um is one option
in design terms um we think we've come
up with actually something better with a
a real sense of place around it um you
know I I think it's a really nice scheme
for three houses and we we're very
content that it works on the site thank
you so if there's no more questions
thank you very much if you'd like to
turn off your video and uh turn the
sound down and listen to the rest of the
debate with us thank you very much
indeed thank you chair um councelor uton
can we now hear from your good self
please thank you
thank you
chairman um has already been said um
I've asked for this application to be
considered as you've seen this is a long
history of applications refused by this
Council and an appeal I believe the
council would be at odds with national
policy guidance and its own planning
policies and then quote hb1 h13 hb2 on
design and residential amenity nowhere
in the draft local plan has this site
been designated as a potential
development site I believe the
application is squeezing in three large
dwellings despite what the Heritage
officer states there states that there
will be little significant impact on
three grade 2 listed buildings plus the
church that in fact has commented that
the design of one of the proposed
dwellings is out of character with the
surrounding Conservation Area and the
conservation area I would remind members
is a category
4 much has been done to preserve that
character he has also asked for
clarification of the red line which
appears to include section of the
curtilage of I believe the um his what
is classified as a historic wall I
believe is actually
listed and it was this wall that the
previous applications achieved to
protect the size and scale are out of
all proportion to the majority of homes
in the location including small flint
and re rendered
Cottages under protect and retain
natural features the planning officer
recommends conditions and in my
opinion too many is still to be
determined and these include ecology
conditions something I am very disturbed
about as we know only too well that
things get cut down and removed and
subsequent action difficult to reverse
and it is very significant that the
ecologist still re retains a holding
objection in the letter dated the 2nd of
December
2020 states that there would be a need
for the removal of some trees to enable
access but we have no details and there
is no sufficient information on
designated sites and legally protected
species what is not obvious in this
application loses an area of open space
which has been a public
imunity and this Council has only last
week agreed to protect green Open Spaces
so to now allow building on a well-used
Green Space will be completely at odds
with the council's commitment to retain
green open spaces for public use and the
mppf clearly states that new development
should be ruled out and to guard against
the loss of valuable Community
facilities which puts this application
if approved certainly would put the pub
at risk
the issue of road safety is where we and
the local community are totally at odds
with suffer County highways the local
community has been as has been said
invited MP Joe Churchill to visit the
site and she too has shown concern at
the overall impact of this on the nature
of the
village so excuse me I am therefore
confused and shocked that we now are
being told by the very late paper that
there is no need to extend the highway
the access onto Church Road is
notoriously difficult and
dangerous the proximity to the blind
Bend upper green and Berry Road means
that drivers need to pull out into the
center of the road to achieve adequate
visibility before entering Church Road
to suggest extending the road run
further onto the highway would surely
make this even more diff dangerous thus
narrowing the highway but now we're
being told that that is not
needed however either way with the
successful Community shop on Church Road
cars the school bus and delivery
vehicles needing to park thereby any
traffic coming from lower Green is is
forced to overtake any stationary
Vehicles pulling into the center of the
road thus facing headon any coming from
the opposite
direction to extend the Highway by
several meters just to give a visibility
play at the cost of safety of other Road
users including pedestrians and those
homeowners of the adjoining Cottages
where there is no foot path on that side
of the road is inex excusable but to
retain the existing is just as dangerous
so I fail to understand the logic and
can only conclude that there is not a
safe access at this site any traffic
survey in the past year has obviously
been unrealistic and in the future would
be completely
different I also believe that this
development would be detrimental to the
viability of six bells how on Earth will
they be able to carry on a successful
business with years of construction
movements in and out of the pub car park
that's aart from the safety aspect for
pedestrians customers and staff and I
urge the committee to reject this
application thank you
chairman thank you councelor Aon that
was very clear um can I have members uh
who wish to make any further questions
councelor Humphrey thank thank
you um just cut the questions and I've
got one a general question which I don't
if Council would be able to answer or
would be an officer but I'll come to
that at the end if I may the first
question is um I'm pretty sure that when
the council voted on the public space
that it meant public space this is a pub
car park and Pub Back Garden so
therefore it's not public uh that's the
first point and also I believe all we
said was that we try and uh provide
public space or green are is for people
within 300 meters of where they live and
I think they've got that with the
churchard and open Countryside very
close by so that's just a question do
you agree with that um I'm afraid I
don't okay um this part of has actually
been used by the community for various
events that has been used as a public
open space thank you but it's not it's
actually belongs to the pub so therefore
it's commercial um which is used by the
public who are actually de it councel
thank you okay um second question um
would you not
also agree with me that whether
development is developed or not that
that access will still be used regularly
by many vehicles accessing the
pub they will be used by and has been
used by the pub but not to the extent of
having an extra at least six Vehicles
constantly moving in and out to the
development
um and obviously taking up space from
the pub car park thank you and the final
question which I think you might need
the help from an officer if I may chair
and that is um you talked about the
viability of the business and the
affecting the business is it not true
that the land belongs to the pub
landlords which I guess trying to look
for a sign probably green King and it's
those people that selling the ground as
is that correct
no thank you certainly not green
King okay does it belong to the pub I'm
not sure to be honest can we have
Clarity on that because it is important
please
yeah I believe it does belong to the pub
but I will just go back to the
application form and just double check
that if if I may um we will show it on
that form thank
you that's an important thing I think
and that's the end of my questions thank
you chair thank you thank councelor
humph um does anyone else have any
further questions for councelor
Ron there is a hand up but I can't see
who it is um it's me chair councelor
Millan yes yes please if you'd like to
ask councelor Aron the question thank
you yeah thank you chair um obviously
this this application sort hinges on on
the the the the access and visibility um
is it typical for when the car park is
full at the pub for for cars to park on
on that sort of lay bar that's been
formed in front of the pub um and and is
that what happens and and how does that
sort of affect the visibility yeah cars
do Park on
there um and how does that affect the
the visibility well it obviously means
that any cars coming round from from as
I say from upper green at the brown at
that bend there need to pull over okay
understand thank you sorry um guests
aren't allowed in this uh question area
now so I'm afraid you can't comment um
any further questions apart from
somebody who is a guest I'm sorry if
you'd like to take your hand down
please right uh councelor Stringer
yeah thank you chair just got a question
and it's about Penny may not be canc may
not be able to answer I'm sure the
officers can the bin collection area and
cycle
store
is that inside the application site
because I'm I'm looking on page looking
at page
228 uh where where it's shown but then
when I look at page
227 it appears to be outside or inside
the red line and and I can't work out
which one it is it's inside the red line
if I was to pull the plan up you the red
line plan comes out slightly in order to
essentially they will share the same
location for Refuge the pub currently
uses now so bins would be effectively
right next to the bins that the pub
would have uh off on the left hand side
as you're going through the driveway I
can't share for a second that plan um
sorry it's not allowing me to um and
also just in answer to the other
question I've got the um the the
ownership certificate served is on horor
Leisure limited that's just sorry to
interrupt yes that's just come to me
it's Hawthorne Ledger that own the part
that's that's the entirety of the red
line so that's all all of those who own
the pub also own all the land in
question so that's one
owner thank you for that um councelor
Stringer have you finished asking your
question your hands still up well yeah
CH if I may just come back on that it's
quite important because the bin area
shows a footpath in front of it on page
228 if I then go to
22 7 and I'm being told it's inside the
red line
I'm struggling to find a driveway
between the pub and the bin store so if
someone could help me because I just
can't see the space I'm sorry it's not
on the
plan right sorry I think it's working um
oh c out loud this just keeps flicking
from one to the other uh so if I was to
can you see this proposed
plan yes yeah can you see the little
markings there that's in terms of the
sort of presentation area for bins bin
they be presented there if I switch then
to the red line plan it's essentially
within that area
there and so so where's the path then
it's it's that little Nick beside
it
um so You' hang on can I zoom in might
be better if I zoom
in oh yes there is a little foot path
there counselor Stringer
yeah does that make it
clearer I still can't I believe a path
if you if you scale that and scale back
to the red line area it looks like it's
narrow see that looks a lot narrower
between the pub and the bins and that
path then that does okay the best
reference is that's the building the
building there and if I then switch over
to that's the building there okay so if
I then and then there's a gap and
essentially the bins are set back here
the path is that Nick there that comes
forward so the bins are set back in
within the red line does that help so
that distance between that path where
the Nick is and that Pub is the same on
that map as it is on the colorful map no
you're right there's a there looks
totally different there is a difference
but of course that's an existing access
anyway in terms of the pub so uh you're
right that red line probably just needs
slight adjustment in terms of it should
line up across
I'm not sorry chair we can't do anything
outside of that red line we can only
look at what's inside that red line but
there's no change outside of the red
line is an existing use and existing
access so it would be covered anyway Ian
can you just um um assist us on that one
please um yeah so if I understood
correctly the case officer is
acknowledging that Landing questions
outside the red line but saying there
isn't existing access in use there is
that right
so the the ACT there's no change
proposed to that part change proposed
right apart from putting bins in that
point so and the bin the bin side of
things is it within the red line so I'm
I would be satisfied if I was an officer
dealing with it well I'm an officer if I
would be satisfied in terms of the
validation of that would be correct I I
admit though in in in Clarity terms it
probably would have been more logical to
make sure the red line just ran along
the building but um given the ownership
of this whole site I'm I'm I'm not
feeling that's a risk but the only other
thing we could ask members to do is if
they were to consider the recommendation
it would be subject to clarification of
that if you like counc Stringer thank
you for raising that issue um and um I
think if we want to debate that further
we can always bring in back in for
clarity should we struggle on it would
you be happy with that
Arrangement yeah happy it's been
answered chair yeah no good thank you
for bringing it up right any further
questions for for councelor uton
I would just say that in my
statement we did query exactly where the
red line is and in fact in the statement
from theage officer oh yes go on he
quered that as well thank you oh you did
right I beg your pardon thank you very
much right okay then thank you councilor
R and we'll move on to the debate then
so if we open up the debate and ask
councelor gold if you're still with us
please if you can um give your thoughts
on this particular site thank you thank
you still here in every sense I hope um
the
I I've got mixed feelings about uh about
this application
um I I
can person my personal uh concern is is
uh is one of the points uh made by
councelor Stringer which is that the the
site seems very constrained it seems it
seems very ambitious to push um three
large houses into such a small space
it's very difficult both from the from
the plan and from the uh 3D uh
projections to get a real sense about
what this is like but it seems very uh
constrained the the other point which is
I totally accept as one of personal
taste is that on such a constrained well
appears to be a constrained site to see
um three different houses uh with no um
kind of sense of uh Unity between them
and I take the liberty of calling mck
bar with Mock edwardi and I'm I'm not
clear how would one would might describe
the the the third house um it's just not
not um to my taste I suppose which is in
is far from being a relevant planning
consider consideration I accept um but
when it comes to it I don't see any real
planning reason for uh for objecting to
this but I'll listen with interest to
what colleagues have to say thank you
very much CH yes thank you very much the
very interesting comments um can we now
move on to councelor humph please thank
you madam chair um yeah I'm going to
start with i' made loads of notes I'm
scrapping between paper here so I'll
move first of all to par 3.1 which is on
page 178 it's important really because
in terms of the appeals there's been
nothing to suggest the principle of
development should be resisted and can
be taken to support the principle of
development that's an important point
that we shouldn't Miss um then we'll
move to uh par 3.2 on page 179 the
appeal demonstrated that the development
of two dwellings was acceptable
including impact on the conservation
area character trees ecology and loss of
open space the only reason for refusal
was the propose removal of part of the
listed War this proposal doesn't affect
the war in the
slightest um although the last uh
proposal was for two buildings or two
dwellings this is now three but um
having looked at the plan in all honesty
in my my perception of it it looks like
a well planned development of three
houses that would fit has been proven to
fit by the drawings on that open space
um so I've got no real problem with that
at all um when it comes to the entrance
and exit to the actual Pub itself well
that's well used as Council arton said
it's well used by people who visit the
pub going into the pub and coming out of
the pub what's the difference we're
talking about three houses and she also
said that this would be six Vehicles
constantly using well that's not true is
it they don't constantly Drive their
cars they'll leave and go to work and
they'll come back just as people leave
the pub or visit the pub there is no
difference to the entrance whatsoever
this is just more Vehicles using the
same access that will never stop being
used as long as the pub is open I don't
see the argument I also looked at the
street view and thank you Mr pman G that
is really useful because now I better
understand it because the actual
entrance I can move forward of the wall
to see right and see left and that's
probably why highways haven't got an
objection to this as well so as far as
I'm concerned the access is the access
it's well used it will be continue to be
well used and the the extra houses make
no difference whatsoever that is the
entrance that is the exit nothing
changes um we'll come on to the immunity
of the the actual or the viability of
the business um that's not for us to
determine in all fairness and the
landlords who own the pub who own the
land have decided to sell that land for
development and that's fine because they
must have done a business viability
check to ensure there's no effect on
their business in fact it might improve
it by three households
so I think that's a smoky mirrors effect
um there's no loss of public space let's
confirm that because this wasn't public
open space it belongs to the landlord
therefore it's commercial and that's the
way it is um I believe the distances
from the uh church and also the fact
that buildings trees Etc between the
line shot of the buildings and the trees
is fine as well doesn't have an effect
on the church at all might benefit the
church in many ways by having more
parishioners and as far as the pub goes
we've already seen that on the appeal
they didn't have an issue with the
conservation side or the listed building
for two houses so the development
they've already agreed there's no reason
why we can't develop this site um I
think I'm pretty much done actually I
think I've cover most things so just to
summarize this area is owned by the
landlord who owns the pub there's no
effect on its business it's an area that
has already gone to uh review and
actually it came back that this is
suitable for development there are no
conservation issues uh and the access
well it is the access it always will be
nothing's changed from last week or six
months or a year ago when it was a very
active Pub um that's it for me thank you
and I will be supporting this
application thank you very much
councelor humph can we have councelor
melon please thank
you yes thank you chair and apologies
again for dropping out earlier
um yeah there is concerns with this
application um and um I I do share
councelor Gold's concerns about the
design of the scheme um that may not be
a particular material consideration but
it does appear to be three you know
distinct houses um where whereas a sort
of coherent design of three similar
houses perhaps I think would have been
better and More in keeping with the
conservation area um there's going to be
some removal of trees to to to get the
access from the back of the car park um
into this new um development and we I
don't I'm not sure I have enough details
about that to be um to be uh sure that
that's appropriate um and then on page
183 of the bundle it talks about
vegetation to be cleared within the
visibility display at the front and I'm
not sure that that is all within the the
uh the red
and in fact within the ownership of the
applicant so I'm not quite sure how that
can be achieved there there is obviously
a concern about um coming out onto the
road uh understand totally that the
previous uh inspector uh on appeal um
thought that the the the access was fine
but that was for two homes and now we
have three so obviously there's an
increased number of of vehicles um I'm
I'm still in two minds about this um but
I'll listen to the debate and and uh and
make my mind up in Du due course thank
you thank you very much counselor and so
we'll now come on to counselor Mayer for
your comments please thank you very
much thanks chair um much of what I
wanted to be to say is already been um
covered um the principle of development
on this site has been established by
appeal
um the visibility spays the access I
think that's almost a red herring in
that the car park is smaller so the
number of residential cars will that be
more or less than the number of
movements into out of the car park who
knows it might be slightly more might be
slightly less but access really hasn't
changed so that doesn't concern me um
so I've also looked and seen that um
previous applications the um the issues
raised have been addressed and on page
180 the um the officer go goes through
and explains how the new application has
addressed many of these issues for me
the one concern I have is as councelor
opon put it that the number of houses
squeezed onto the site and even then
it's probably not the number of houses
the fact there three large houses
squeezed onto a site three large houses
that seem to be out of keeping with
other houses in the area um The Gardens
looking incredibly small and as as
councelor Stringer has
identified backing up turning around
getting in and out of your car parking
space will be difficult why because I
think too much has been squeezed onto
this site I would be much happier if it
were three smaller houses or indeed two
large houses on on the plot my personal
view is that I think this this plot is
in danger of being overdeveloped and
will therefore have a negative impact in
on the um the houses around so
I'll listen to what else has been said
from the other counselors but I I I
don't feel this application is yet good
enough um to get my support thank you
thank you for that and now we have
councelor Norris if you would
please thank you yes um yes I also have
some reservations uh there still seems
to me to be some questions about the
safety of the access which appears to be
on a long Bend um the site isn't in the
draft local plan for
development and again the size and mass
and scale of the proposed dwellings that
are squeezed into this site in relation
to the surrounding buildings seems out
of
keeping uh insufficient information on
ecological impact has been mentioned so
at the moment I'm not inclined to
support this application but I will
listen to the rest of the debate thank
you thank you councelor Norris councelor
Stringer uh thank you chair yeah I think
this one is uh one that sort of starts
off looking fairly straightforward and
ends up looking incredibly complicated
uh and I'll try and simplify it I I in
its present State cannot support this
application for a variety of policy
reasons uh one of the policy reasons to
gp1 is the designer buildings should
actually protect res residents amenities
uh and I'll come back to that in a
minute U h15 says that we should respect
local characteristics and enhance them
uh T9 also suggests traffic policy
suggests that the maneuvering of cars
should be safe and also respect that
amenity and for me how contrived this
application is to get those car parking
spaces in there means that people are
going to be driving in front of other
people's houses all the time just to
access their parking space all because
we're trying to cram so much into a
courtyard development now I'm not sure
if Courtyard developments are a local
characteristic I can't find many of them
in the local area so for me I think this
is all just trying to put too much into
too little space without respecting
enough of of that local character so I
agree with councelor mayor that perhaps
if one of these dwellings or two of
these dwellings were smaller it would
just ease all of this uh or if they were
just two larger dwellings would probably
be fine but I think what we're trying to
achieve here is something that will
become unsustainable development if it's
built like this because the entire front
of this development as you approach it
is
dominated by car movements the whole
thing is going to be a giant roundabout
and our policies Clearly say that we
should not have development that is
dominated by the car and frankly this
development as drawn here is going to do
precisely that so in this current form
chair I cannot support this application
thank you thank you and now we move on
to councelor warboys please if you'd
like to say say your piece please yes
just get
my there we go
uh thank you chair yes I find myself in
in agreement with Council Mayors and
Stringer
um I I I put myself on a point of view
of um a future resident of this
development and uh having bought my four
bedroomed house find I'm sharing a very
small plot with two more four bedroom
houses and
um having to negotiate sh coming in and
out of the house with not only my
neighbors but also sharing the driveway
with a a public
house um I think it is very very much a
case of of overdevelopment on this site
I I went along with Council umre his
comments about there's um a principle of
development established there
and two dwellings have been
mentioned with a shared access but this
but this is another dwelling too far I
think
um the um quite rightly the the
um the
village the parish is put forward you
the development is in The Gardens of the
pub no direct Road access in the heart
of the village and its Conservation Area
surrounded by 14 existing
properties um th this development is
quite out of scale with the majority of
those properties it would actually sort
of I I think been visible over the
rooftops and I think you have a a loss
of amenity to be considered on behalf of
those
residents um so I don't feel I can
support this development in this this
form um the good design uh paying a a
sort of homage to Georgian converted
barns in a sort of vernacular flint and
brick development I think that I I think
there there is scope here for for some
an an interesting a new design um
perhaps it should be S considered
something more contemporary rather than
sort of a pasti of older
buildings so thank
you thank you for that councelor war
boys um well I must admit I've been
listening to everybody um and many of
their comments I agree with um from
everybody that's said and spoken um we
haven't yet got a suffk design guide
although that has been discussed
recently and I was on the group that was
discussing it um I did question earlier
on that it was originally two properties
and now we've got three the principle of
development is there and we can't get
away from that um the highways issues I
think my concern the only well not the
only concern my concern for that would
be if there are children in these
properties that want to walk to the shop
and they would have to in inverted
commas run the gauntlet down the exit um
with
cars um I also think if there's um
children's play equipment you have
bicycles and sometimes a football and so
on two dwellings um look rather good to
me and I don't buy the argument that um
the uh exit could could not be used I
think for two dwellings it would be
acceptable but there is still that point
about children walking down there is
this overdevelopment of the
site that's the big
question uh so that's where I'm at at
the moment so if we'd like to go around
again and and see what anybody would
like to propose thank
you so do we want want to start again at
the top with councelor ghoul do you want
to oh councelor humph you you had your
hand up I beg your pardon councelor
humph sorry madam chair I was just going
to jump in if nobody if you hadn't
started so I'm happy to go back to the
alphabetical thing if you like I I'll
put my hand down thank you all right
okay fair enough councelor G do you want
to sort of pass further now you've heard
other comments from everybody
else uh no this there seems to be a
degree of um not among everyone but that
there does seem to be a kind of common
view emerging this but I've got nothing
to add myself at this point Thank You
councelor
Humphries Madam chair thank you um I'd
just like to go back to my point that um
3.2 and 3.1 sort of cover it clearly
that you know um this is a super area
for development um the access point is
the access point won't change and
nothing changes and I forget which
councilor came on but actually with the
reduction in car parking space at the
back of the pub actually the numbers may
be similar that might be councelor mayor
uh in quantity so therefore I don't see
there's an issue with that I get your
point about the the children walking
down the the pathway I live in a small
cyac it's not as pretty as the one that
you see on the map in front of you but
we've got the same problems but you know
what that's modern living um and I know
it's not the best and the most ideal
situation in the world but it doesn't
prevent development it just means we
need to be careful as far as counselor's
uh counselor string is point about
Vehicles dominating that's a very strong
word isn't it what does dominate mean it
means be the most important conspicuous
person or thing have commanded position
or I don't understand the word so we're
not dominated by the car because cars
are used by people they will always be
used by people whether it be electric
diesel or petrol and people need to
access the houses and just like the cck
I live in right now people actually do
Drive in front of other people's
properties to access theirs that's
modern living um it is what it is I'm
afraid um we talked about the
domineering effect of these buildings I
understand that these buildings are
lower than the buildings that were
originally going to be put up and
probably lower than the standard uh and
perhaps an officer could confirm that in
a moment um I do get the point however
on design um I think the domineering
building is the barn and if that Barn
could be rendered as a condition i'
would be much happier to be honest you
that's my only issue with this whole
thing is the barn um the Georgian
looking houses to me look really good
good uh I think it's a great setting for
them as well a third one similar to that
would be fantastic so change the barn
get rid of the black domineer effect
good word domineering in that respect um
and basically render it um I've got no
issue with this and I I would re I'd
find it really hard to find a reason for
refusal a legal reason unless anybody
knows better I'd be very interested in
the officers coming back to discuss
Heights please thank you um yes Heights
and also um if we did request render
does that have to um be deferred to look
at or can we make that adjustment now so
um Gemma first of all Gemma is the
officer assisting me today so if we
could um have that from you please I can
see John's got his hand up but I'm
asking that's fine yeah I wouldn't have
a problem with potentially a not
withstanding the design condition would
agree a scheme for rendering so it would
allow us to take that away have a look
at it that that said not withstanding
the current design we would like to
agree a scheme for rendering of the I
think we described it as the barn
property I'm sure we can put a plot
number to that I'm sure John will help
me out with that plot number but yes I'd
be content plot one thank you John but
are are you suggesting it has to be
deferred to do that or are you
suggesting we can do it now I I was
suggesting if members were minded to
approve I wouldn't have a problem doing
that by condition so that the condition
would be not withstanding the detail on
the plan there should be a scheme to
render the barup plot one right and that
we would agree that in in future as a
part of a discharge of condition does
that answer your question councelor
humph Madam chair yes um and if that was
the case I would be minded to move uh
for approval right thank you very much
indeed and do I have a seconder to that
proposal
please looking
round well I will second that proposal
as I can't see anyone else so I will
second that because I think um councelor
Stringer did say that that was sort of
quite prominent um and I think if that
were changed that would improve the look
of it um and also um when we looked
around at some of the photographs coming
in there was I don't know whether it was
a church school or whatever there was a
nice big window so that sort of sits
comfortably in the area as it were so um
yes I'd be happy to Second it thank you
I'm sorry madam chair sorry my apologies
we didn't get the height confirmation
from the I be your pardon um I think
it's 7 point something isn't it um we
did have that before and perhaps John
could help us on that please so so the
plot Heights are in in your papers in
terms of The Proposal I think you were
referring to the previous two uh the
previous two were individually larger
properties I've got um I've got it is
yeah so they were similar Heights in
terms of there were 7.3
7.5 uh but they were both large
two-story properties that and with
weather boarding and
render um am I permitted to just mention
a couple of things if I may um I will
say that designs come up here in terms
of
um the uniformity of the
threee the thing interesting thing with
with with felim is actually there's a
lot of differences with all John I don't
think you should really be debating I
will leave it there it is what it is it
was the height that councelor humph that
was more interested with I thought you
gave us the heights early or at some I
can yes um this is the problem of having
a computer that isn't helpful
today um bear with me I will just back
I'm sure we've discussed that before so
the plot one is uh 7.9 to the ridge uh
with Eaves Heights that range between
2.3 to 5.1 M plot two is 7.6 m to the
ridge again with each Heights around
about 5 m uh and then you got plot three
which is 7.4 M with again e Heights
around about 5
m does that help you councelor humre
from from
that thank you madam chair sort
of supports my this this is fine for
that particular area thank you thank you
does anyone else wish to talk to the uh
recommendation please
The Proposal councelor Stringer thank
you yeah uh I'd like to speak against
the proposal if I
may yes the clarification on height was
really interesting an average large
house is 7.5 MERS tall um that's the
average these days the the tallest one
here is 04 of a meter bigger than that
taller than that so it's not it's not
within local characteristics or even
current uh Heights it's taller than than
most others this applic if approved will
not reflect local car characteristics it
will be completely against
h15 uh yeah filum is not full of C full
of these these Courtyard developments uh
sb2 says that we need to protect the
privacy and amenity of neighboring
properties the neighboring properties in
the new build here will have and I take
Council hre's point about he lives in a
cesac people drive past him but they
don't drive he hasn't got a roundabout
outside his house which is what these
houses have basically have an effective
they have a roundabout in front of their
house purely because they're trying to
cram too much in to a too smaller space
and if you are sitting in in that house
and you've constantly got your neighbors
just driving past your front door
turning as they're doing it uh that
front that whole area at the front is
dominated by traffic movements it does
nothing else it just for it just as a
mini roundabout to get cars into a a
cramped confined area how on Earth you'd
walk through I don't know you just got
to make sure there's not a car there
then you'd be able to walk but there'll
be no you can't put clear paths through
because the thing is roundabout because
we're trying to cram too much in gp1
says proper provision should be made for
parking and turning and I think if you
honestly look at how you would root cars
in an of the parking spaces in here it
isn't proper you can do it on a good day
but it will affect residential amenity
because if I lived in a cuer saac of
three houses I wouldn't expect all three
of them going round whizzing round in
circles in front of my house just trying
to enter and exit a parking space
because someone has designed this too
cramped so I'll be voting against this
application thank you chair thank you
councelor Stringer who else would like
to speak to the motion please
councelor humre did you want to speak
again Madam chair yes please it bit of
compromise really I get Council
stringer's Point um so if there was a
condition to remove the roundabout would
that not satisfy his
concerns if if I if I could come back uh
no because it would be further dominated
by the car movements you you you you
wouldn't be able to get a car into the
center there easily so that's not what
we're faced with we have what's in the
plan and the plan does not respect local
characteristics or proper provision for
car parking movements that wouldn't
dominate this
development thank you gentlemen um so um
who else would like to speak or do we go
to the vote on this
now right in that case then may we go to
the vote um and can we add the condition
that um
councelor Humphrey's recommended that uh
GMA Walker agreed to which was to
render uh the the current Barn type
property plot one I believe
please thank you chair I'll just read
out because I've been in contact with my
colleague um the area planning manager
regarding that point so I'll just read
out what I put into modern doov so that
um Council humph and yourself as
seconder can just agree that this is
what we'll be voted on that application
dc20
04572 be approved as detailed in the
officer recommendation with the
additional condition as follows not
withstanding the proposed design of plot
one a scheme to render that dwelling
shall be
agreed are you happy with that councelor
humre Madam chair yes thank you and so
am I okay thank you then chair well I
will now start the vote on that so if
members could please go to the modern.
goov app and go to the plus sign in the
top right hand corner there it will give
you the subsection on voting and
attendance if you click on that it will
show the vote votes for today and this
one will appear in a light blue
color
Madam chair if I may uh my voting button
isn't working so I'll be voting for
thank
you thank you chair so with that with
Council Hy's vote taken I can confirm
that that is three votes for and five
votes against so the motion is
lost thank you very much indeed so can I
well done counselor Stringer before I
even ask the question could I propose
that we refuse this application on
policies h15 T9 SP2 and
gp1 and the reasonings behind that is
h15 the development does not reflect
local
characteristics uh gp1 there isn't
proper provision for parking and
maneuvering sb2 privacy and amenity of
neighboring properties I.E the other
properties on this site and uh T9
maneuvering U and equally within gp1 uh
there is residential amenity in there uh
caused by the uh not not proper
provision for
parking you mean loss of residential
amuny sorry yeah loss of yeah well
that's what the policy is up to fine
thank you for that do I have a second to
that
please councelor War
boys councelor War boys are you
seconding that
please sorry talking to myself yes I'm
happy to um support
that thank you for
[Music]
that
yes I hope we
are
just been trying to capture all of
councelor stringer's
uh points on that one I'm not sure I
have so it might help if we could run
back over
those well I'm sure cancel a Stringer
account but I've got h15 T9 gp1 and sb2
well perhaps if I share with where I had
got to is based on the the conversations
and those policies so that the proposal
would by reason of poor layout design
and scale create a cramped and contrived
overdevelopment of the site which would
be out of keeping with the character of
the locality and we would be detrimental
to the local distinctness of this part
of fum contrary to gp1 and
hp5 sorry h15 uh as a whole this
proposal represents a very poor design
dominated by parking that results in a
detrimental impact the functional
arrangement of the layout is considered
poor and fails to provide proper parking
provision cont local plan policy h15 but
I think I probably hadn't captured the
maneuvering and Immunity aspects cancel
string you want to amplify that I've got
it written down but you can it when when
you said it's it's po poorly parking
it's the maneuvering that's actually the
greater issue than the parking itself
although that does create issues Super S
but and sorry trying to R reason while
while we're here so I've amended did the
second part so as a whole this proposal
represents a very poor design dominated
by parking that resulted in a
detrimental impact the functional
arrangement of the L is considered poor
and fails to provide proper maneuvering
provision uh and that's contrary to
local plan policy h15 and
T9 so is there more about SP2 that you
would like hang on hang on hang on J
it's that first part of that sentence
you said dominated by parking it's
dominated by parking and maneuvering Y
and
maneuvering
[Music]
and far be it for me to add something to
this but um councelor Stringer did you
want to add something regarding the red
line area or
something well I mean is that IR I think
that that would be up to someone else to
look at I mean if this gets appealed
they can unpick what is actually in the
application what isn't yeah
okay
okay so
um I think
I've revised that slightly so I can just
run through that again thank you for
bearing with me on this one there's a
lot of different issues I think to
capture so just want to make sure I've
caught them all for you satisfactorily
so the proposal would by reason of the
poor layout design and scale create a
cramped and contrived over development
of the site which would be out of
keeping with the character of the
locality and would be be detrimental to
the local distinctiveness of this part
of fum contrary to local plan policies
gp1 and
h15 as a whole this proposal represents
very poor design dominated by parking
and maneuvering that results in a
detrimental impact that would fail to
protect the immunity of properties cont
to policy sb2 the functional arrangement
of the LA is considered poor and first
to provide proper man maneuvering
provision contrary to local plan policy
h15 and
T9 you said that far better than I could
and councelor War boys as the second you
have your hand up what would you like to
say yes I I think I'd like to pick up on
something uh that you said c councilor
Guthrie uh about the
um the um safety aspects with regards to
children and whether that sort of lack
of immunity as well should be considered
in this poor design that no provision is
is really made for young children well I
think we're sort of um well well you're
entitled to say that of course you are
and I did say that yes um you'd have to
ask councelor Stringer if he wishes to
add any amendments to it I I think I
think it almost goes along saying that
there isn't proper parking um you know
or your maneuvering safely it it is part
of the T policies about maneuvering uh
T9 does mention I think you know uh was
it gp1 mentions being able to walk in
and out and safely as well so there is
there is an element to that but it's it
was the sheer domination of the whole
design is about getting cars in and out
and little else can happen there uh you
can't even store a bin because they have
to be stored up the road because it's
it's so cramp
so I think so if I might interrupt there
councelor Stringer um the highways have
sort of not commented on safety so I
think you've captured everything in what
you've already proposed would you
agree I I agree I agree right thank you
I will go along with that too thank you
thank you nonetheless thank
you have we got that up as a
voting do you need the text
Rob
suggest um for the sake of e um in this
case is if I ask would it be appropriate
to put into the recommendation for
members to um that the application be
approved um for the reasons as read out
by the chief uh sorry I've I've given
you a promotion there J I apologize um
by by the area planning manager um and
then they'll be added into the reasons
on the website following this meeting
would that be acceptable
chair well it would for me but would it
for legal are they happy with that um
hello sorry I'm here Madam chair as long
as members know what quite all members
are quite satisfied they know what
they're voting for yes it would be all
right with
me thank you then in that case off we go
thank you and whilst I'm just putting
that my final touches on that could I
just ask then just for clarity as Mr
dea's outline then just ask G to read it
out one final time so that we're all
clear thank you chair yeah no thanks Rob
I just did want to say so we're looking
at refusal not approval I'm sure that
was just a the tong just to make sure we
get that correct on the vote that would
be fantastic so this is a now a reason
for refusal so the the reason would be
the proposal would by reason of poor
layout design and scale create a cramped
and contrived overdevelopment of the
site which would be out of keeping with
the character of the locality and would
be detrimental to the local
distinctiveness of this part of fum
contrary to local plan policies gp1 and
h15 as a whole this proposal represents
a very poor design dominated by parking
and maneuvering the results in a
detrimental
impact that would sorry I've missed a
word that would fail to protect the
amenity of properties contrary to local
plan policy sb2 the functional
arrangement of the layout is considered
poor and fails to provide proper
maneuvering provision contrary to local
plan policies h15 and
T9
thank you chairman with your commission
chair I will go and start the vote yes
please if you would thank you very much
thank you chair so if members could
please again go to the modern. goov app
and go to today's agenda in the top
right hand corner you will see the plus
sign if you click on there will open the
subsection on voting SL attendance after
clicking on the voting SL attendance tab
you will see the votes for today and the
voting progress will be shown in a light
blue line about halfway down the page
thank you chair we've now received all
votes for the vote so it is by five
votes to three the motion is
carried thank you very much indeed and
thank you very much to everybody for
their input today um I don't have any
site visits planned um I haven't been
informed of them so I think I can now
close the meeting and thank everybody
and apologize for those that have got to
whiz off to another meeting thank you
thank you
thank